Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Sag mal, wie findest du eigentlich Österreich?
Auf einer Karte müsste ich suchen.
Lochbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 466 vom 17.
Dingsbums August 2023 live vom Chaos Communication Camp 2023 in Mildenberg.
Wir sagen hallo, herzlich willkommen, viele Gäste, seid willkommen!
Und ich meine, warst du schon mal da?
Österreich?
Ja.
Ja, ja. Also ein Flugzeug fliegt da eigentlich zielstrebig hin.
Und wie hast du es so gefunden, als du es gefunden hast?
Ich war ja immer nur in Wien. Oder war ich mal woanders? Salzburg und Österreich?
Ja.
Ja, da war ich auch.
Das war's? Salzburg und Wien? Echt?
Ja. Gibt's noch mehr in Österreich?
Ja. Was denn? Graz.
Da war ich nicht.
Da gibt's Kürbiskernöl. Das machen die auf alles.
Auf Eis, auf Steak, auf Fisch, auf deine Kartoffeln, die kippen dir das wahrscheinlich
sogar noch in die Cola, wenn du nicht aufpasst.
Also, fandst du gut da? Ja, also mit dem Kürbiskübel, der das irgendwann über
hat, aber ansonsten alles sehr hübsch da und also ich kann nicht klagen.
Und ich war auch schon mal in Linz, Linz ist auch sehr schön, hat einen Fluss.
Da ist dieses Kunstding.
Genau, die Ars Electronica, die hat schon mal einen Pokal eingesammelt.
Vokal für die, wie hieß die noch mal, die goldene Nika, für das Lebenswerk,
aber nicht meins, so weit ist es noch nicht.
Nee, für die CCC, der hat nämlich da die goldene Nika bekommen für sein Gesamtwirken.
Ja, die stand dann jahrelang in der Meta-Ebene.
Nee, die stand nicht jahrelang in der Meta-Ebene, die stand immer noch in der
Meta-Ebene, Weil natürlich der Rest des Haufens davon nie so richtig Notiz genommen
hat und ich immer Angst hatte, dass wenn das jetzt irgendwo im Club steht,
dass das dann einfach bei irgendeiner Aufraumaktion wegkommt.
Oder LEDs irgendwo dran macht oder so.
Also bisher wollte es noch keiner zurückhaben. Ja. Das ist für mich so ein bisschen
ein Ausgleich. Also so hab ich dann zumindest das Gefühl, ich hab mal einen
Preis gewonnen. Hast du schon mal einen Preis gewonnen?
Ich hab in der Schule mal bei so einem Zeichenwettbewerb gewonnen.
Was hast du gemalt?
Ähm... Kopflose Leute, die sich mit Baseballschlägern hauen.
Dafür hast du einen Preis bekommen?
Ja, es war Comics gegen Gewalt.
Ach, du hast so eine Woche keine Schule oder so, ja?
Nee, einen Scanner. Ich hab einen Scanner bekommen. Was hab ich noch für Preise? Lass mir überlegen.
Naja, okay, gut. Also...
Die anderen Preise sind uncool.
Österreich, wir werden gleich viel über Österreich reden. Bevor wir über Österreich
reden, müssen wir vielleicht nochmal kurz hier was zum Kontext sagen.
Chaos Communication Camp, wir haben es ja schon erwähnt, das gibt es alle vier
Jahre, so auch dieses Jahr.
Es ist ein weiteres Mal in Mildenberg und es ist sehr bunt, oder?
Also das kann man auf jeden Fall schon mal festhalten, Dinos.
Du musst mir jetzt zustimmen.
Ja, ja es ist bunt.
Was guckst du nur?
Also haben wir was Falsches gesagt?
Es ist bunt. Ja, also ich stehe da vollkommen außer Frage, dass es bunt ist.
Genau. Du hast auch schon einen Vortrag gehalten.
Ich hab einen Vortrag gehalten, ja. Wie war's? Zusammen mit meinen Kollegen
und Freunden Dominik und Cantorkel haben wir über unsere Hacking-Abenteuer gesprochen.
Einmal in der Disclosure von Vulnerabilities, so als CCC.
Leute sagen hier übrigens ihr habt eine Schwachstelle und dann haben wir das
irgendwann noch ein bisschen verschärft durch,
dann haben wir mit kleinen Hinweisen eine Ransomware Gang übernommen und haben
dann die Leute gehackt, also die Ransomware Gang hat Leute gehackt und wir haben
den Leuten gesagt, ey Achtung, ihr werdet gerade gehackt, macht das weg und
das war ganz interessant eigentlich.
Okay.
Und das haben wir gestern, aber auf Englisch. Deswegen habe ich dir nicht Bescheid gesagt.
Du sprichst ja deine eigene Muttersprache nicht.
Nee?
Nicht so gut.
Das ist nicht meine Muttersprache.
Ich weiß, Deutsch ist deine Muttersprache, aber jetzt hast du ja auch einen
Pass. Jetzt kommt er halt mit dem Pass.
Du hast das Thema aufgebracht. Ich wollte da gar nicht drüber reden.
Hast du einen deutschen Pass?
Nee, leider nicht. Ich hab sogar Asyl beantragt in Deutschland.
Ja, ich hab das mal gemacht.
Wir müssen jetzt mal ein kleines Ratespiel machen. Also melden sich mal bitte
alle, die wissen, wer er ist.
Du musst jetzt 5 Prozent. 5 Prozent würdest du sagen?
10 Prozent? Da hinten sind noch welche.
Keine 10 Prozent. 5 Prozent. Unter 5 Prozent. Ich sag unter 5 Prozent.
Jetzt kommen die vorsichtigen Hinweise. Ich stelle jetzt was auf den Tisch und
zwar ist das eine Flasche Wodka.
Wie viele wissen jetzt, wer er ist?
Also jetzt dürfen sich nur die melden, die... achso, nee, ist okay,
ist immer noch fünf Prozent, okay.
Jetzt stellen wir Red Bull dazu.
Weiß jetzt jemand, wer das ist?
Immer noch dasselbe.
Wer von euch hat einen Pass von Spanische Insel? Ibiza oder so?
Wie viele wissen jetzt, wer er ist?
Bisschen mehr.
Boah, das ist ja unglaublich.
Was denn? Na ja gut, ich meine, wir haben die Geschichte ja auch noch nicht
ausreichend erzählt, glaube ich.
Also das ist Julian Hessenthaler.
Hallo. Genau.
Herzlich Willkommen. Danke.
Und wenn man mit Julian Hessenthaler Wodka Red Bull trinkt, ist das üblicherweise ein Karriereende.
Und wir haben uns überlegt, wir versuchen diesen Bann mal zu brechen,
diesen Fluch, und lassen uns einfach drauf ein und trinken jetzt mit Julian.
Oder wir riskieren auch das Karriereende.
Karriereende Wodka Red Bull, genau.
Bin ich froh, dass du mir kein Glas hingestellt hast.
Doch, das steht hinter deinem Bildschirm.
Ah, furchtbar. Darf ich an dieser Stelle meinen tiefen Dislike aussprechen zum
Thema Red Bull? Das ist einfach für mich...
Heißt doch gar nicht Red Bull, ne? Heißt doch Rasenballsport.
Hör bloß auf. Wenn das meine Fußballfreunde hören, dass ich Red Bull trinke...
Ja, aber einmal hierzu...
...würde ich der Kurve verwiesen.
So, die Eiswürfel sind...
Super vorbereitet. Du willst mehr Eis?
Nee, nee, geht schon, alles gut. Weil du hast gesagt, du möchtest so viel Wasser
und so wenig Red Bull wie möglich?
Ja.
Dann nimm mehr Eiswürfel.
Ihr ahnt es schon, wir müssen über Österreich reden. Das klingt immer so ein
bisschen wie so eine Ermahnung.
Wir haben ja nun auch im Podcast schon mehrfach über Österreich geredet und
es ist immer super, um so ein bisschen die Hände über den Kopf zusammen zu schlagen.
Aber es ist auch nicht alles schlecht, was aus Österreich kommt.
Allerdings Red Bull schon.
Ich verstehe überhaupt nicht, wie dieses Zeug... Also, warum?
Ich verstehe nicht, warum meins lila ist, aber egal.
Oh, das ist das Red Bull Blue. Sorry.
Passt zu FPÖ. Alles gut.
Okay, ich muss das jetzt hier... Is peer pressure at work. Wie viel macht man
auf... Oh Gott, das ist ja...
Du kannst auch mehr Wodka machen.
Der ist ja beides schlimm. Ja, den Wodka schmeckst du nicht mehr drauf.
Ich muss doch noch einen Podcast machen heute.
Ja, du musst das ja auch nicht austrinken.
Ist das so richtig?
Ja, kannst du machen.
Muss man halt wollen. Kommt darauf an, was du noch vor hast.
Oh Gott.
Ich hab eigentlich nichts mehr vor. So, Julian, vielen Dank fürs Kommen,
dabei sein. Ganz toll. Ja, auf dich, ne?
Auf Österreich, Julian. Pfui.
So, wie viel muss man davon trinken, bis man die Krone verkaufen will?
Strache hat ein paar gebrochen, sag ich mal. Aber er wollte es doch nicht verkaufen,
muss man ehrlicherweise sagen.
So, für alle, die immer noch completely lost sind, worüber wir jetzt hier eigentlich
reden wollen und wer das ist und überhaupt und so weiter. Wir haben es ja im
Podcast auch ein paar Mal angesprochen und die Sache ging auch irgendwie um
die Welt, also zumindest in der deutschsprachigen Welt. Ich weiß gar nicht,
ist das so international eigentlich auch irgendwie?
Ich sag mal, das Video, der Release wohl schon, aber der Nachgang dann überhaupt
nicht. Das ist GAMP, glaub ich, weltweit, weil ich hab tatsächlich die Freigaben
zeichnen müssen, jeder Einzelnen, was mich ungefähr zwei Tage lang Zeit gekostet hat.
Hat.
Irgendwelche verschlüsselten E-Mails an einen speziellen...
Ein spezielles E-Mail-Postfach zu schicken, in dem ich den diversen Sendern Freigaben erteile.
Interessiert sich eigentlich irgendjemand für Österreich?
Sollte. Also ganz erst sollte man, weil tatsächlich Österreich auf einem recht
seltsamen Weg unterwegs ist die letzten Jahre und das wird irgendwie nicht besser.
Ach du meinst so in a bad way sollte man sich für Österreich verstehen?
Ja, so in a strange way. In a dubious way.
Genau, super interessant in a strange way. Genau, also wir reden natürlich über
die ganze Ibiza-Affäre,
ausgelöst, nicht ohne deinen Zutun, da wollen wir jetzt auch gleich nochmal
drüber reden, da gab es dieses ominöse Video, wo sehr viel Wodka Red Bull getrunken wurde.
Und was dann so in der Folge allerlei Aufhebens gemacht hat und letzten Endes
zum Sturz der Regierung kurz führte,
also die ÖVP-FPÖ-Regierung und ja, seitdem geht's ja auch holterdiepolter wild weiter.
Man kann darüber reagieren, ob da sich jetzt was verbessert hat oder nicht,
aber zumindest hat sich mal was verändert. Das kann man auch auf jeden Fall festhalten.
Ja, ich glaub wir haben den fünften Bundeskanzler im vierten Jahr noch, also.
Ja, genau. Dieses Video ist von 2017, das ist, wenn ich mich jetzt richtig erinnere,
vor den Wahlen, wo es dann zu dieser Koalition kam, aufgenommen worden.
Zwei Jahre später erst wurde es publik.
Und dann dauerte es nochmal so ein anderthalb Jahr und dann kamst du,
oder ja, ich weiß nicht ganz genau.
Bis zu meiner Verhaftung hat es dann anderthalb Jahre gedauert.
Genau, aber dein Name fiel dazu.
Relativ gleich, es war aber auch klar, es war absehbar.
Aber nicht sofort, ne? Also es war sozusagen ein ganz kleines Rätsel für kurze Zeit.
Genau, und dann war sehr viel Brimborium und Aufhebens und Fingerpointing und
natürlich wie das eben bei solchen Affären ist, wo mächtige Schaden nehmen,
da wird dann erstmal ordentlich dran gearbeitet, möglichst die ganzen Messenger zu erschießen.
Und du bist zwar nicht tot, so, aber ganz schadfrei bist du ja aus der Sache
nun auch nicht hervorgegangen.
Auch nicht, ne.
Genau. Soviel vielleicht mal so als Kontext, da habt ihr ja sicherlich alle
schon mal was von gehört.
Jetzt würde mich natürlich trotzdem nochmal interessieren, um das mal so ein
bisschen auch festzumachen, wie bitte kam es dazu eigentlich?
Also wie weit müssen wir jetzt in der Geschichte zurückrudern?
Tja, eigentlich also kurz, wenn du es ganz kurz runtergebrochen haben willst, ich hab da nicht...
Nee, du kannst das auch ausführlich blumenreich ausführen.
Bei Thilo Jung bin ich vier Stunden gesessen, glaube ich.
Ich weiß nicht, was wir uns hier rausschmeißen, aber kommt eigentlich noch irgendwas nach uns?
Nee, go on.
Ich wusste nicht, wer den Marktplatz auflegen will, aber ihr könnt ja ohne.
Das machen wir mal im Detail.
Das Camp geht auch noch zwei Tage.
Stimmt auch wieder, ja. Nee, kurz gesagt, ich hatte einen Freund, der war Anwalt.
Und der kam irgendwann zu mir und meinte, der hat einen Mandanten und der hat
ihm irgendwelches so brisantes Material anvertraut und war so relativ geheimnistorisch, sag ich mal.
Und peu a peu hat er mir dann mehr oder weniger durchgesteckt, okay,
er geht so eine Strache und der Mandant ist halt offenbar Bodyguard vom Strache und der hat gesammelt,
alles mögliche Material, unter anderem Fotos von Geldtaschen im Kofferraum vom
Strache und Rechnungen, die angeblich gefälscht sein sollten,
damit er irgendwie seine private Lebensführung mit Spesen an die Partei verrechnen kann.
Und das Material war interessant, aber es hat keine Beweiskraft gehabt,
also es waren halt Fotos und die kann jeder machen und es waren halt irgendwelche
Ausdrucke von Rechnungen, die kann auch jeder mit Photoshop herstellen,
wenn er will. Also am Ende, ja.
Die Geschichte war wohl schon glaubwürdig für mich, aber beweist halt nichts
und er hat mich dann gefragt, ob mir was einfällt.
Mir war das eigentlich, war wirklich nichts politisch ambitioniert oder wie
auch immer. Es war mehr so, da war ein Freund von mir, der hat halt so gewusst,
was ich tue. Ich war eben in der so privaten...
Was hast du denn getan?
Wir haben Sicherheitsberatung genannt, also wir haben Großkonzerne beraten.
Im Endeffekt haben wir, was im Englischen heißt, Private Intelligence Rent gemacht.
Also Großkonzerne geschützt, einerseits vor Informationsabfluss etc.,
das ist nicht im IT-Bereich, sondern eher so im Real-World-Bereich und auf der
anderen Seite eben auch präventive Sachen, Richtung Patentverletzungen etc.
Und deswegen wusste er halt, dass ich so ein gewisses Talent in der Richtung
habe, ein gewisses Know-How, Skillset, wie auch immer.
Und hat mich eben gefragt, ob mir was einfällt und ich hab so salopp hingeworfen,
ja nee, du brauchst halt irgendwie ein Audio-Video, wo der das halt zugibt,
mehr oder weniger am besten.
Klar.
Wir haben uns regelmäßig, muss man sagen, ähnlich wie heute hier,
mit ein paar Wodka getroffen nach der Arbeit.
Auch mit Red Bull?
Ohne Red Bull tatsächlich. Das war Strache sein Drink, nicht meiner.
Ist zu meinem dann geworden, leider.
Und ja, wie es halt so ist, wenn man zu viel Wodka trinkt, kommt man auf lustige
Ideen. Und seine lustige Idee war, hey, komm, lass machen.
Und ich hab das nicht ernst genommen am Anfang, bis er dann tatsächlich ein
Packen Geld ausgepackt hat und gemeint hat, und er meinte, komm, was kostet's?
Organisiere es mal. Und ich habe gesagt, okay, cool.
Aber was war denn seine Motivation?
Ich glaube tatsächlich, also durchaus, er war schon ideologisch motiviert,
sage ich mal. Also der war deutlich politischer als ich zu dem Zeitpunkt,
mit Sicherheit. Also als Perser muss man dazu sagen.
Damals war schon absehbar, dass die FPÖ in die Regierung kommen würde.
Und wenn man halt irgendwie so gelernter Ausländer in Österreich ist,
dann weiß man, dass das nicht so sonderlich gut für einen ist.
Und ja, das war wohl sicher mit ein Grund. Auf der anderen Seite,
glaube ich, war ihm wohl auch, wahrscheinlich wollte er einfach auf was bewegen.
Ich glaube, das kennt jeder, wenn man halt mal so einen etwas trockenen Alltag
hat, dass man dann halt auch manchmal das Gefühl hat, hey jetzt komm,
lass mal irgendwas machen, was so was anderes ist. Und das war wahrscheinlich
auch mitgespielt im Rückblick.
Und so kam's. Wir haben dann ein paar nicht so wirklich professionelle Versuche
unternommen, sage ich mal. Also ich glaube die Geschichte ist oft erzählt.
Der ohne die SD-Karte?
Ja, ohne die SD-Karte. Aber das macht dich auch menschlich. Ja, absolut.
Das beweist, die menschlichen Fehler sind überall zu finden.
Was war denn mit den SD-Karten?
Der Punkt war also, vielleicht zuerst mal, ich habe mir gesagt,
ich muss irgendwie an Strache rankommen. Also wenn ich in der Lage sein soll,
jetzt den Strache irgendwie in eine Falle zu locken, muss ich irgendwie an Strache ran.
Keiner von uns beiden kannte den Strache. geht gern weg und das Strache macht
gern Party und sonst was.
Aber du gehst jetzt nicht in irgendeinen Club und sagst, hey Strache,
komm mal, wir haben da irgendwie super geile korrupte Sachen zu bereden.
Das heißt, das funktioniert auch in Österreich nicht.
Und so kam halt die Idee, dass der Anwalt kannte eine Maklerin,
eine immobile Maklerin und die war mit der rechten Hand vom Strache,
hatte mal eine Affäre gehabt, mit dem Strache übrigens auch.
Und ich war übrigens auch Ausländerin.
Nur so nebenbei gesagt und da kam die Idee daher nach gut,
der Anwalt war Immobilienanwalt unter anderem, hat gesagt, na komm ich ruf die
Markerin an und sage ich habe eine super wichtige Kundin oder Kunden,
der will in irgendwelche Ländereien kaufen und zufälligerweise hat diese rechte
Hand vom Strache, der Godenus sich nennt, die Familie hat da Ländereien recht
weitreichend, außerhalb von Wien.
Und dann kam uns halt mir die Idee, na komm, lass uns eine Legende kreieren
und ich wollte im Ganzen damals, weil Österreich mittlerweile etwas offensichtlicher,
aber damals auch für jeden der sehen wollte, so eine seltsame,
Liebe zu Russland pflegt, also
so irgendwie Russland ist so ein recht gewichtiger Faktor in Österreich.
Diese Karin Kneisel ist jetzt nach Russland gezogen.
Ja, ja, die hat auch heute irgendwie getwittert, dass es super geil ist,
besser als Malediven und sich schellen und so.
Also die ehemalige Außenministerin, ne?
Ja, also ehemalige Außenministerin in Österreich, FPÖ. Hier wohnt jetzt irgendwo
in Russland der Papa. Hat mal Putin zu ihrer Hochzeit eingeladen,
Putin hat sich tatsächlich die Mühe genommen und ist mit einer Konvoi nach Graz,
glaube ich war es, gefahren, weil du gerade Graz gesagt hast.
Und hat dort mit ihr getanzt und sie hat sich dann verbeugt vor Putin.
Da gibt es wunderschöne Fotos zu finden.
Als sie Außenministerin war.
Als sie Außenministerin war, ja.
Was ist denn geil?
Da ist bestimmt auch irgendwas mit Kürbiskernöl gelaufen oder so.
Man weiß es nicht. Aber ja, jedenfalls das Foto gibt es. Das Foto hat für Aufsehen gesorgt.
Er hat ihr dafür ein Maragdohrring für 50.000 Euro geschenkt,
die sie mal gleich eingesteckt hat und versucht hat mitzunehmen.
Das ist so süß.
Also was ich so geil finde an Österreich ist, die bemühen sich noch nicht mal
irgendwie seriös rüberzukommen, also hier tun sie ja zumindest noch.
Ja ich sag ja, das ist der Unterschied zwischen solchen Leuten,
weil alle mir so sagen, überall sind Politiker korrupt, ja stimmt schon,
aber in Österreich ist es tatsächlich so, die machen sich nicht mal die Mühe.
Also in Italien sitzt du bei irgendwem, keine Ahnung, der will halt bestochen
werden und dann dreht er sich um und zeigt dir das Bild hinter ihm,
das fürchterlich unwichtig ist und sagt so, hey, was wäre denn das da wert und
dann verstehst du, was er will.
Und in Österreich hört es dann einfach so, gib mal, hier ist die Anzahl.
Und das ist relativ absurd, aber es zeigt auch, dass in Österreich offenbar
so eine Kultur eingekehrt ist, wo die Leute sich absolut keine,
also wo sie sich eben sicher sind.
Das Problem ist wohl nicht, dass die Leute in Österreich besonders dumm,
blöd oder korrupt sind, möglicherweise manche, aber nicht alle,
aber das Problem ist tatsächlich glaube ich eher, dass die Leute tatsächlich
davon ausgehen, dass ihnen keine Konsequenzen drohen. Und die machen es deswegen.
Einfach so sich eingeschliffen hat, dass sie einfach sicher sind,
dass egal was passiert, bei CERN passiert.
Und dann ist es natürlich unglaublich leicht korrupt zu sein,
weil wenn am Ende des Tages das Schlimmste, was droht, vielleicht ein Rücktritt
in irgendeinen Vorstand ist, dann ist es ja wohl auch egal.
Ist denn das ein neues Phänomen oder ist das etwas, was du sagen würdest,
was so inhärent in der österreichischen Kultur so drinsteckt und schon irgendwie immer?
Ich sag mal, Österreich ist für viele Sachen, speziell auch im Technikbereich,
wie ich so mitgekriegt habe, so ein Testballon ein bisschen,
also so UMTS-Netzwerk und so weiter, also klassische Dinge wird in Österreich
getestet, weil so ein kleines Land und doch gut ausgebaut, infrastrukturmäßig.
Auf der anderen Seite ist Österreich halt auch fürchtlich hinterher.
Also ich glaube, wenn man es vergleichen wollen würde, Deutschland hat in Bayern
diese Spesen-Skandale vor mal Ewigkeiten gefühlt.
Und das ist so ungefähr, wo Österreich jetzt steht. Also damit kann man vielleicht
deutlichen was zu der Punkt...
Schlimmer als Bayern.
So scheint es zumindest. Es gilt die Unschuldsvermutung, wie man so schön sagt.
Heute geht es für Tim aber richtig rund. Erst Rasenballsport trinken,
dann gibt es noch was Schlimmeres als Bayern.
Naja, aber ich meine jetzt, ich versuche gerade so rauszukriegen,
ist eigentlich irgendwas, also manchmal ist es ja schon die Geografie eines
Landes, die in irgendeiner Form so bestimmend ist, inwiefern das jetzt bei Österreich
eine Rolle spielen kann, keine Ahnung.
Oder irgendein anderes Element, was sozusagen so spezifisch irgendwas in der
Gesellschaft ermöglicht, was woanders so,
nicht ohne weiteres… Das ist so der österreichische Take on things.
Und das setzt sich fort. Österreich hat eine geile Kultur entwickelt,
keine Verantwortung zu übernehmen.
Wir sind nicht NATO-Mitglied, aber mein Gott, wir werden halt geschützt,
weil überall rundherum NATO-Länder und wir brauchen eigentlich auch die EU nicht,
aber irgendwie ist es doch ganz geil.
Österreich entwickelt sich so ein bisschen. Ich glaube Österreich grenzt halt nur mal an Ungarn.
Und die haben gesehen, das was der Orban da abzieht, das funktioniert irgendwie
so halbwegs gut. Und warum machen wir es nicht auch, weil es ist ja gut für uns.
Dann kommt dann die alte Habsburger.
Ja, also dieses Monarchische schwingt schon noch mit. Also auch die vote Einstellung
gegenüber dem Staat ist glaube ich in Österreich doch recht ausgeprägt.
Im Gegensatz zu Deutschland. Ich habe das gemerkt in meinem Verfahren,
das dann gelaufen ist. laufen ist, die waren komplett schockiert,
weil meine deutschen Anwälte halt angriffig waren. Die haben halt gesagt,
ihr seid korrupt und was alles nicht falsch ist.
Die Reaktion der Staatsanwaltschaft in Wien darauf war, dass sie mal meine Anwälte
angezeigt haben, weil sie sich ungebührlich gegenüber der Staatsanwaltschaft verhalten haben.
Also eine Obrigkeitshörigkeit kombiniert mit einem Hang zur Korruption.
Kombiniert mit so einem gewissen Hang zur Inszenierung und Operette.
Also Österreich ist, es muss nur gut ausschauen.
Österreich ist wichtig, dass es gut ausschaut. Vielleicht haben sie von Bayern
übernommen, dieses schicke Micky Ding ist so ein bisschen in Österreich angekommen
und Hauptsache es glänzt auf der Oberfläche und drunter. Nicht so wichtig.
Wie so ein Ölfilm auf dem Ozean.
Ja, möglicherweise.
Ja, ach Österreich.
Aber dann ist es ja trotzdem, jetzt kurz vorspringen, also immerhin war es ja noch ein Skandal.
Ja, nee, aber es war ein Skandal. Ich würde heute noch immer behaupten,
dass es waren ja Esszeit und Spiele, also deutsche Medien und durchaus Schwergewichte
in der Medienbranche in Deutschland, die veröffentlicht haben und waren auch
die Medien, die wir uns gesucht haben dafür.
Und ich bin bis heute noch der Überzeugung, wenn du das österreichischen Medien
gegeben hättest, hättest du schon welche gefunden, die es veröffentlicht hätten.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass du welche gefunden hättest, die sich getraut hätten, das Video zu bringen.
Die hätten transkribiert, die hätten mit Untertiteln belegt oder sonst was,
weil einfach Österreich hat unter anderem viele Probleme,
ich lasse uns noch ein paar davon aufzählen, die Medien hängen alle an der staatlichen Subvention,
werden also gefördert und die können sich zwar erlauben kritisch zu schreiben,
aber da gibt es dann schon so Abstrafungen, also diese eine Boulevardzeitung,
der man aktuell in Ermittlungsverfahren unterstellt, die Umfragen für den ehemaligen
Bundeskanzler Kurz manipuliert haben,
damit er gewählt wird, kriegen, glaube ich, keine Ahnung, das ist eine Gratiszeitung,
die kriegt man gratis in der U-Bahn ausgelegt, kann man so nehmen und die kriegen
keine 5 Millionen Förderung im Jahr.
Die kriegen 5 Millionen staatliche Förderung im Jahr und werden dauernd verklagt,
weil sie lauter Schwachsinn schreiben und das zahlen sie aus der staatlichen Förderung raus.
Ist ein Geschäftsmodell, nicht schlecht.
Wie heißt das Blatt?
Österreich.
Vielsagend. Und Qualitätsblätter werden dann totgehungert. In Österreich kannst
du es dir nur bis zu einem gewissen Grad wirklich leisten.
Damit will ich jetzt nicht den österreichischen Journalisten Unrecht tun.
Also es gibt schon Leute,
die sich keinen Blatt vor den Mund nehmen, aber es gibt halt,
man merkt schon, dass es so Themenbereiche gibt, die maximal dann so ein Journalist
aufgreift, die werden dann aber auch relativ schnell irgendwie weggeschoben
mit, naja, kommt das links-linker Journalismus oder Lügenpresse.
Das gewinnt dann nicht die Art Gewicht, die das Video mit einer Veröffentlichung
durch Resset und Spiegel gewonnen hat, weil da konnte man, also das kann man nicht wegwischen.
Und Österreich ist halt immer noch sehr dran gelegen im Ausland,
weil wir sind ein Touristenland und das ist einfach für den Tourismus nicht
gut, wenn klar wird, dass Österreich halt irgendwie so eine korrupte Halbbananen-Republik
ist, da quatschen wir nicht so gerne hin.
Sondern man will in ein ordentliches, alpines, strammes Land fahren zum Skifahren.
Aber nicht, dass man was gegen die Korruption tut, sondern man redet einfach nicht drüber.
Ja.
Okay, das ist auch straight forward. Jetzt nochmal zurück zu dem Video.
Also du bist jetzt von deinem Anwalt angesprochen worden und dann hast du dich
so ein bisschen beim Wodka verleiten lassen und hast Ideen entwickelt und dann
habt ihr das sozusagen auch in die Tat umgesetzt.
Ihr habt ihn angesprochen, ihr habt über diesen Gudenos sozusagen diesen Kontakt
gefunden und dann kam es ja letzten Endes zu diesem Happening.
Vielleicht kannst du ja nochmal so ein bisschen darstellen, wie das dann kam.
Warum Ibiza und wer war überhaupt die Russin?
Ja, wer die Russin war, werde ich jetzt mal nicht, weiterhin nicht darlegen,
aber lassen wir es mal so stehen.
Ne, der Punkt war, also ich hab eine Legende kreiert, dass es eine Oligarchenlichter
gibt. Wir haben die in den Familienkreis eines recht bekannten Oligarchen gerückt,
der nachher auch ziemlich pisst war drüber, muss man sagen.
Was war denn der offizielle Name? Ist der bekannt?
Der ist schon bekannt, der hat auch diverse Leute losgeschickt,
um herauszufinden, wer diese besagte Oligarchin war etc. Ich will ihn jetzt
nicht noch weiter provozieren, seinen Namen weiter hier auftragen,
aber man kann's googlen, man findet's.
Jedenfalls habe ich eine Oligarchin kreiert, die angeblich seine Nichte wäre mit irgendwie so,
keine Ahnung, knapp 350 Millionen Schwarzgeld, das aus dem zusammenbrechenden
Laundromat-System herauskommen sollte, die eben gerne, wie so viele andere reiche
Russen, aus irgendeinem Grund nach Österreich kommen würde und dort ihr Geld
gerne anlegen würde bzw.
Auch vielleicht zäubern wollen würde. Das war die Ursprungsgeschichte.
Dadurch, die Idee war, wir kaufen also Ländereien vom Gudenus als Entree.
Evaner, sagt ihr das dann auch? Also ist das auch genau so, wie du das jetzt gesagt hast?
Ja, nee, wir haben ihm, das ist on tape, wir haben ihm gesagt,
das ist kein Drogengeld.
Ja, es kann auch nicht auf einer Bank.
Wo wollte er das denn hin tun?
Die Idee war, wir haben dann tatsächlich, also das ist eben was man bei Ibiza
vielleicht vergisst, weil die Leute bei Ibiza das Gefühl haben,
okay, das war halt ein Abend und die haben gesoffen und scheiße geredet.
Wir haben da sieben Monate lang Verhandlungen geführt und wir haben recht komplizierte
Konstrukte gebaut. Also wir haben gesagt, okay, wir gründen eine Firma,
eine zweite Firma, die kauft jetzt Immobilien, dann blasen wir mit Gutachten
die Werte der Immobilien auf, verschieben es auf die zweite GmbH rüber.
Die macht dann mit Belehnungen und Besicherungen bei Banken Kredite,
holt sich also über die erhöhten Gutachten Geld da rein, wascht so das Geld
durch. Wir zahlen es aus, wir teilen es. Da gab es Vertragsentwürfe.
Es war schon recht gut durchdacht. Das war jetzt nicht einfach nur,
hey komm, Vodka, Red Bull und lass uns quatschen. Ja. War schon mehr als das.
Und jedenfalls gab es diesen ersten Abend, weil du eben die SD-Karten angesprochen
hast, wo wir dann richtig große Show gefahren haben. Also wir haben da,
keine Ahnung, ich habe eben diese Oligarchin gefunden, diese Oligarchin-Nichte,
eine Bekannte von mir, die ich für ideal geeignet gehalten habe. was sie auch war.
Und haben in Maibach gemietet und Bodyguards und irgendwie eine super teure
Private Dining Room in einem 5 Sterne Hotel und was es schießt mich durch.
Und sind halt dort vorgefahren und haben gesagt, hey komm, da jetzt großes Happening.
Und der Gudenus ist halt einfach wie so viele in Österreich dumm und gierig,
muss man einfach so sagen.
Und hat uns halt versucht seine Ländereien, die so 5 Mille wert sind, für 12 anzubieten.
Und wir haben gesagt, ja ist kein Problem, weil wir haben sowieso genug Geld
zu waschen, aber dann wollen wir Extras.
Und damit haben wir mal angetestet, wie es weitergeht.
Und es ging dann auch recht weit. Also man muss sich vorstellen,
das war das erste Mal, wo man sich trifft. Man hat noch nie vorher telefoniert,
man hat noch nie vorher geredet.
Und da sitzt du dann mit jemandem und sagst ihm so, ja, also wir hätten gern
so irgendwie Bewaffnete Sicherheitsleute.
Du kannst es mit der Polizei irgendwie so klären. Ja, geht, wahrscheinlich kennt
er irgendwie die Feuerpolizisten oder so.
Und da haben wir eskaliert, da haben wir halt so gesagt, ja gut, okay.
Also wir wollen Langwaffen, ja schwierig, aber ja, okay, geht.
Und so ging's da hin.
Und ja, also der erste Abend war, dann ging es eben weiter von einem Hotel in
eine Bar und dort haben wir dann,
weil wir wussten, dass, ich muss jetzt ein bisschen vorsichtig sein,
aber sagen wir mal, es ging das Gerücht um, dass der Herr Gudenus gewissen Substanz
nicht abgeneigt wäre und da haben wir uns halt gedacht, komm,
tun wir in dem Gefallen auch noch.
Und haben eine Suite in dem, das war so ein Rooftop Hotel Bar,
haben wir gesagt, okay, damit er die Chance hat dort also belegbar seinen Habits
nachzugehen, mieten wir also eine Master Suite und bieten ihm an,
statt dass er aufs WC rennen muss, wir sind cool genug, dass wir ihm also dafür
die Master Suite zur Verfügung stellen.
Was dann auch angeblich passiert ist, da war ich leider nicht dabei,
und dort hatten wir eben Kamerasysteme platziert. Ich muss dazu sagen,
ich habe noch nie vorher mit Kameras gearbeitet gehabt.
Und ich bin froh, weil ich es nie wieder machen muss, ehrlich gesagt, weil es scheiße ist.
Und der Punkt war, ich hatte also diese Kamerasysteme gekauft bei irgendeinem
etwas fragwürdigen Garagenladen, der so China-Importware hatte,
weil ich einfach ein Zeitproblem hatte.
Und war naiver, dummerweise davon
ausgegangen, dass die wahrscheinlich mit SD-Karten bestückt sein würden.
Was sie nicht waren. Wie ich nachher herausgefunden habe am nächsten Tag.
Also es kam dazu, dass wir also eine Menge Geld verballert haben in dem Abend,
Riesenshow gefahren haben, eigentlich relativ erfolgreich waren.
Das Problem war nur mal, es gab überhaupt kein Videomaterial,
weil halt keine SD-Karten in der Kamera waren, was den Anwalt nicht glücklich
gemacht hat, weil das so knapp 30.000 Euro seines Geldes waren,
die überhaupt nicht verflogen sind.
Und das hat dann dazu geführt, dass er sein Handy bei mir gegen die Wand gepfeffert hat, die Oligarchie.
Der war schon mal 1.000 Euro mehr.
Ja, nee, das Handy hat's überlebt, war ein iPhone, gute Qualität.
Aber nee, der Punkt war, die Oligarchie ist in Lachen ausgebrochen und hat sich abgekugelt.
Und mir war's halt peinlich, unglaublich peinlich, klarerweise.
Und dann hab ich halt groß gemeint, damit das Thema irgendwie vorbeigeht,
ja komm, dann lass einfach nochmal machen. Wir wissen ja jetzt,
dass es geht. Wir machen das nochmal.
Und das haben wir dann auch einfach nochmal gemacht. Das hat auch erfolgreich
funktioniert. Deswegen gibt es so schöne Bilder von Herrn Gudenus,
wie er sich über den Tisch beugt und irgendwas sucht mit dem Nasenloch.
Und da war aber noch immer der Strache nicht anwesend. Also es hat eigentlich
geheißen, er bringt uns zum Strache und irgendwie hat der Strache nie Zeit für uns gehabt offenbar.
Und dann kam der Gudenus eben durch mit der Info, ja, er fliegt jetzt nach Ibiza
und der Strache ist auch dort. Und ich habe mir gedacht, na komm, was soll's.
Ja super, die hat eh ein Haus in Ibiza, wir fahren auch nach Ibiza, treffen uns dort.
Natürlich hatte sie kein Haus in Ibiza, das musste ich anmieten.
Das Problem war auch noch, der Anwalt hat keinen Bock mehr gehabt,
das anzumieten, was ich anmieten wollte, was so ungefähr 10.000 den Nacht gekostet hätte.
Und deswegen wurde es dann eine kleine Finca, was alle bemängelt haben nachher
so quasi, oh mein Gott, wie soll das eine Oligarchenvilla darstellen.
Aber fairerweise, man muss sagen, wir haben auch nicht gesagt,
das ist die Oligarchenvilla, gesagt, die Oligarchen-Villa, das sind ihre Kinder
und ihr seid so komische Typen, ihr kommt nicht zu ihren Kindern nach Hause, keine Chance.
Deswegen haben wir ein anderes Haus gemietet, wo wir jetzt quatschen.
Und so war es dann auch. Die sind also gekommen, wir haben uns da extra irgendwelche
Sportwagen und sonst was gecheckt, damit es zumindest ein bisschen oligarchen-style ausschaut.
Und haben halt kräftig angekauft, Wodka etc. Und so entstand dann das,
was man heute essen kann.
Und Red Bull.
Und Red Bull, ne Menge Red Bull. Ganze Palette, glaube ich, oder zwei sogar.
Also so kam Ibiza zustande und ich glaube der Rest ist relativ bekannt.
Wenn man... Also... Dass das grundsätzlich irgendwie funktioniert, das war... Applaus,
Also einerseits mit den Fuck-Ups, ne, aber andererseits auch wenn diese Dinge
passieren, da muss einem...
Kriegt man da nicht irgendwann mal so richtig, also hast du dir irgendwann nicht
mal gedacht so, bin ich bescheuert, was mach ich hier eigentlich?
Oder sind die um dich herum einfach alle so doof, dass sie auch..
Das war eher der Punkt. Also mich hat schockiert, wie doof die waren oder wie
naiv die waren, weil ich komme aus dem Sicherheitsbereich und wir haben auch
irgendwie jetzt so Kunden von uns, Klienten von uns geschult.
Und ich habe die ganze Zeit gewartet, ok, wann kommen die Sicherheitschecks?
Also irgendwie, ich war auch schon
in anderen Ländern mit irgendwelchen politisch nahen Leuten am Tisch.
Und sogar bei irgendwelchen Staatssekretären hast du mal irgendeinen Sicherheitsdienst
oder sowas, der dich mal zumindest passt, sonst was, OpenSearch,
OpenSource Intelligence, was auch immer.
Und da kam überhaupt nichts. Also die hatten tatsächlich, das muss man sich
mal verbildlichen, wir diskutieren also sieben Monate lang über die Waschung,
Investitionen, von 350 Millionen Euro Schwarzgeld, die Manipulation von Wahlen und Medien.
Und die haben von mir einen Vornamen, den sie nicht geprüft haben und eine Wegwerfnummer,
also ein Burner-Phone. Das war's.
Das war alles. Also, Profis, Profis.
Ich würde das ein bisschen anders interpretieren, wenn jemand das alles macht,
ohne jemals irgendwie zu überlegen, hmmm, vielleicht...
Hat er das schon vorher gemacht, ja klar.
Genau, dann hat er das schon vorher gemacht. Das finde ich halt wichtig,
das auch an der Stelle nochmal zu betonen.
Also der Punkt ist, weil die Leute ja teilweise einen Vorwurf gebracht haben,
dass das nicht so Stasi-Methoden sind, also dass da jemand in die Falle gelockt,
aufgenommen, das ist so irgendwie fragwürdig moralisch. Habe ich auch sogar
von Leuten gehört, die jetzt sicher nicht unbedingt in den Freundeskreis der
FPÖ oder Rechtspopulisten zu rücken sind.
Man muss dabei bedenken, wir haben jetzt nicht irgendwie gesagt,
hey komm, lass probieren, ob das funktioniert, sondern wir hatten Material durch
diesen Bodyguard, das zwar nicht beweiskräftig war, aber doch eindeutig war.
Und darauf haben wir aufgebaut. Also wir sind jetzt nicht hingegangen und haben
gesagt, hey die FPÖ ist scheiße für uns und lass mal schauen, was geht.
Sondern wir haben halt gesagt, okay gut, wir sind uns eigentlich absolut sicher,
dass der korrupt ist, aber wir können es halt momentan noch nicht wirklich beweisen.
Was oft ein Problem bei Korruptionssachen ist. So ein klassisches Problem,
das haben wir ja auch letztes Mal irgendwie, jetzt wie ich mich mit Journalisten
doch immer wieder unterhalten habe, haben die gesagt, hey, du hast keine Ahnung,
wie oft zu uns Leute kommen mit den wildesten Geschichten von Korruption.
Und dann sagen wir ihnen, okay, beweise. Und der sagt, meine Zeugenaussage.
Und der sagt, ja, was soll ich mit deiner Zeugenaussage, was bringt mir das?
Und da ist halt das Problem bei Korruption, Korruption ist halt eines der wenigen
Delikte, wo eigentlich kein Opfer da ist. Ich meine, es gibt schon Opfer,
natürlich, die Gesamtheit, das Volk, die Bevölkerung, wie auch immer.
Aber das Problem ist, es gibt also kein Opfer, das jetzt sich beklagen würde,
weil im Endeffekt, wenn Korruption funktioniert, sind alle Seiten zufrieden.
Und deswegen ist Korruption so ein einerseits wahrscheinlich anziehendes Delikt,
wenn du so willst, oder apartes Delikt für manche Leute.
Auf der anderen Seite so schwer dann wirklich zu verurteilen.
Es gibt halt oft Gerüchte über Korruption und auch Sachen, die wohl rational
klar sind, aber halt gerichtsmäßig nicht beweisbar sind. Und das spielt wohl sicher mit an Rolle.
Also ihr wart euch die ganze Zeit sicher, dass es klappt. Ihr hättet sonst den
Aufwand auch nicht betrieben. Nee, es hat mega, mega geflossen.
Schon wirklich enorm und das Ergebnis, ja, sehenswert kann man sagen. Habt ihr!
Damals schon damit gerechnet, welchen Impact das haben würde?
Ne, schau, der Punkt war, also wir wollten ja eigentlich, was wir immer die
ganze Zeit erreichen wollten, war den Strache strafrechtlich für seine angenommen
korrupten Handlungen, muss ich mal sagen, es gilt die Unschuldsvermutung, zu belangen.
Und die Idee war also, der Bodyguard hatte Material und eine Zeugenaussage,
die aber nicht beweiskräftig war.
Die Idee, warum das Video entstanden ist, war, um den Bodyguard glaubwürdig
zu machen. Was wir also machen wollten war, der Bodyguard sollte,
der verlangt auch noch Absicherung, aber ein anderes Thema, der sollte also
in die Öffentlichkeit gehen und der war Polizist gleichzeitig.
Das heißt, er hatte seinen Amtseid verletzt, indem er nicht sofort das selber
gemeldet hatte. Also er hatte sich schon mal strafbar gemacht,
was natürlich seiner Glaubwürdigkeit nicht unbedingt zuträglich ist.
Und der hätte also in die Öffentlichkeit gehen sollen mit seinen Vorwürfen und
seiner Zeugenaussage, worauf der Strache dann natürlich gesagt hätte,
ha ha ha, kann ja jeder erzählen und ein paar blöde Fotos kann auch jeder bringen.
Und in dem Moment, wo er dementiert und sagt.
Das ist alles scheiße, dann legst du das Video hinterher und damit ist er dann
richtig am Arsch, sag ich mal.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz war er ein Whistleblower und ich fand es nicht illegitim,
der Wunsch nach Absicherung war für mich jetzt nicht illegitim.
Das finde ich nämlich auch mal wichtig zu besprechen. Der hat also im Prinzip eine...
Darum gebeten, einen Geldbetrag zu bekommen, dafür dass er letztendlich sein Leben ruiniert.
Ja, also was er wollte, er wollte jetzt auch keinen Geldbetrag haben,
er hat gesagt, schau, das wird mir eine Anklage einbringen, ich verliere meinen
Job wahrscheinlich, meine Pensionsbezüge, alles, ich habe Frau, Kind etc.
Aber was er wollte oder was zur Diskussion stand, war sowas wie eine Art Treuhandkonto,
was gesucht wurde, war also die Einrichtung eines Betrages, den er definiert
hatte, der sich danach ja sogar halbieren ließ, aber trotzdem nicht erreichbar war bei Weitem.
Der war auch relativ hoch, also wollte er anfänglich 2,5, was ich weiß,
dann 1,2,5 und der Punkt war also, es hätte dann quasi ausgeschüttet werden
sollen im Art Treuhandsystem, Escrow Service mäßig.
Der geht, macht seine Aussage, wird belangt und dann fängt an das Geld zu fließen
nach Bedarf. Das war jetzt nicht, dass man sagt, hey komm, hier ist ein Kofferbargeld.
Plus muss man dazu sagen, ehrlicherweise auch noch, weil das Leute so immer
riskiert, warum jemand jetzt irgendwie siebenstellige Beträge haben will,
so ein Geld muss auch noch versteuern.
Auch. Also das ist nicht, der Coutinho ist nicht ein Schwarzgeldgipsen,
sondern der zahlt 50 Prozent Steuern weg davon nachher und dann ist das,
finde ich jetzt, Verhältnismus ist guter Rat.
Natürlich kann man es besser finden, wenn der irgendwie sagt,
okay, ich will abgesichert sein oder ich will das aus ideologischen Motiven
machen und egal was passiert,
aber ich finde es jetzt nicht illegitim, wenn jemand sagt, okay,
schau, am Ende des Tages muss ich nachher weiterleben, weil auch ich habe die
Erfahrung gemacht, Also das hat schon recht beachtliche Konsequenzen,
wenn man sowas macht und kostet auch eine Stange Geld.
Und ist also, ja, fand ich sicherlich wünschenswert gewesen,
es wäre anders möglich gewesen.
War es dann am Ende nicht, lange Sache, kurz gesagt. kurz gesagt und deswegen
kam dann eben zur EU-Wahl dann das Ibiza-Video raus, weil das dann eigentlich
so ein letztmöglicher Termin war, wenn man internationale Aufmerksamkeit haben
wollte auf absehbare Zeit.
Da war Strache dann schon in der Regierung, was auch so ein Problem war,
weil davor hatten wir einen Oppositionsführer auf Video, wo er mehr oder weniger
sich halt blamiert und korrupt sitzt oder mutmaßlich korrupt ist.
Und jetzt hatten wir einen Vizekanzler auf Video, dem seine Partei auch noch das Innenministerium,
das Verteidigungsministerium innehatte und damit alle sicherheitsrelevanten
Behörden an dem seine Partei eine unglaubliche Nähe zu Putin-Russland pflegte
und diverse Gerüchte im Raum standen,
dass da engste Verbindungen bestehen sollten, was auch noch mal ein Problem ist,
weil natürlich, wenn das so wäre,
angenommen es gilt auch hier die Unschuldsvermutung, dann wären die Russen wahrscheinlich
nicht sonderlich erpicht darauf, dass man ihnen genau das ins Gesicht drückt,
was sie auch lustigerweise nicht waren, weil tatsächlich hat sich dann der Kreml
gemüßig gefühlt sich zu äußern, Beziehungsweise Ibiza-Videos.
Und wenn sich der Kreml dann offiziell zu was äußert, dann weißt du,
dass du ziemlich weit auf den Radar aufgepoppt bist.
Und vielleicht auch andere Probleme hast, als nur die FPÖ.
Ja, vor allem die Russen, die wissen, wie sie mit Problemen im Ausland umgehen
können. Ja, ja, das haben wir gemerkt. Es war die Zeit von Skripal etc.
Da kam der Maaseleck daher und ist mit der Novichok vor einmal spazieren gegangen.
Du hattest also schon durchaus berechtigte Angst vor der Veröffentlichung.
Ja, also das war auch mit ein Grund. Es gab sicher auch Momente,
wo ich gesagt habe, ich scheiß drauf, ist einfach zu riskant, lass stecken.
Es war so ein permanenter Kampf auch mit mir selber und mir war mehr als bewusst,
ich meine mir waren nicht alle Auswirkungen bewusst, aber mir war schon klar,
dass mein Leben kräftig in die Tonne kippen wird mal für das nächste Zeit.
Hast du es denn bereut?
Nee, ehrlich gesagt nicht wirklich, weil es ist,
einfach...
Es ist so viel Scheiße, sag ich mal ganz offen salopp gesagt,
an die Oberfläche gekommen, die sogar für mich tatsächlich undenkbar war, also denk-unmöglich.
Das sind Sachen passiert offenbar, die so absurd sind und so grenzwertig sind,
dass es einfach, es gibt so ein Limit bei allem, weißt du, es gibt so ein Limit,
wo man irgendwie Sachen akzeptieren kann und wegschauen kann und dann gibt es
irgendwie so einen Punkt, wo du sagst, hey, ist zu viel.
Und der Punkt war einfach erreicht. Es gibt sicher Sachen, die ich bereue bei
der Durchführung, also speziell hinsichtlich dessen, dass, wenn ich's nochmal
machen müssen würde, dann würde ich's mit professionellen Dienstleistern anlegen.
Ich hab tatsächlich auf Bekannte und Freunde zurückgegriffen und die haben relativ
harte Repressalien teilweise auch erfahren und das war auch sicher teilweise ungefragt.
Also es war jetzt nicht, die haben nicht gesagt, ich hab nicht gesagt,
komm wir machen jetzt das und das ist der Plan und die haben gesagt,
ich bin dabei. Die haben gesagt, ich brauch ein Gefallen, das kannst du jenes
machen. Und die sind dann auf einmal auch da multiple Hausdurchsucht worden,
sonst irgendwas, das ist halt alles nicht schön.
In den Medien verrissen worden, gehetzt worden und die haben halt nicht wirklich,
ich meine sie wussten zwar ungefähr, warum sie da mitmachen,
aber im Detail nicht. Und mit Sicherheit wussten sie nicht, worauf's rausläuft.
Da ist schon etwas, was man sicher auch mit sich trägt.
So gesehen das mit Sicherheit bereue ich, auch was andere Leute betrifft,
aber wie gesagt, also hört sich vielleicht dämlich an, aber die Zeit vor der
Veröffentlichung war meine beschissenste Zeit.
Also sogar die Zeit im Gefängnis war besser als die Zeit vor der Veröffentlichung,
weil nach der Veröffentlichung war es so,
weiß nicht ob man das irgendwie verstehen kann, es war als ob so eine Riesenlast
von dir runterfällt, davor bist du halt die ganze Zeit, du tragst mit dir rum,
von dem du weißt, dass es irgendwie die Welt nicht verändert,
aber zumindest viel Veränderung anstoßen wird und...
Und vor allem passieren ja dann auch Dinge, die du dann gar nicht mehr unter
Kontrolle hast, auf die du gar nicht mehr reagieren kannst, weil das ja schon
passiert ist, wie zum Beispiel, dass sie dann in der Regierung waren und sicherlich
auch noch ein paar andere Aspekte.
Ja, sicher. Es waren viele Sachen. Ich muss sagen, ich habe vieles davon antizipiert.
Also mir war schon klar, in welche Richtung die Angriffe bei mir gehen würden
und welche Vektoren das sein würden. Ich habe dem auch versucht vorzubauen in gewisser Art.
Ich hatte viel Zeit nachzudenken und ich bin ganz gut in strategischer Planung etc.
Und hab also vieles davon antizipiert, manches davon abfedern können,
manches davon hat mich komplett überrascht, manche Sachen.
Aber im generellen, sage ich jetzt, hat es sich im Rahmen meiner Erwartungen
bewegt, mit einigen Ausreißern über die Amplituden hinaus.
Aber mir war schon, also wenig von dem im Großen und Ganzen,
was passiert ist, hat mich wirklich dezidiert überrascht. Ich hätte mir gewünscht,
dass es nicht so ist, ich habe auch alles dafür getan, dass es nicht so ist,
aber es war jetzt nicht komplett undenkbar für mich vorher.
Ich komme nun mal aus einer Branche, wo ich durchaus einen Einblick habe,
wie Behörden arbeiten, speziell in Österreich.
Und mir war schon klar, also ich weiß, meine Anwälte haben mich für verrückt
erklärt, wie ich damals kam.
Die haben gesagt, die werden mich zumüllen mit fingierter, zusammenerfundener Scheiße.
Die werden mich versuchen, mit allem zu belegen, was geht. Die haben gesagt,
komm, ist ein EU-Land, ist ein Rechtsstaat, ist am Ende wie Deutschland.
Keine Chance, ich sage, ich glaube, ja doch, genau das.
Und dann kam es, ich hab dann tatsächlich alle meine Anwälte bekehrt.
Also ich hab Anwälte gehabt, die tatsächlich inbrünstig an den Rechtsstaat geglaubt
haben und die nach meiner Verurteilung,
wie mir gesagt wurde, dann irgendwie bei zugezogenen Jalousien eine Woche im
Büro gesessen sind und niemanden sprechen wollten, weil ja die komplette Welt
zusammengestürzt war, weil die gesagt haben, das geht nicht, das kann nicht sein.
Und ich bin da deutlich zynischer eingestellt, also ich hab schon Sachen gesehen
in Österreich, die halt die meisten Leute zum Glück nicht sehen und ja.
Aber du bereust es trotzdem nicht? Du bereust es trotzdem nicht?
Nicht die Tat, aber halt die Umstände.
Ich bereue es tatsächlich nicht.
Das finde ich ja sehr wichtig, das auch zu...
Ne, weil ich bin doch dann irgendwann so, ich bin jemand der recht stur wird,
wenn er der Überzeugung ist, recht zu haben.
Und ich bin dann auch, für mich war es auch bei einem gewissen Grad klar,
dass ich schmerzen oder leiden werde, wenn du so willst.
Und da war so irgendwann der Punkt, wo ich gesagt habe, okay,
komm, dann lassen wir mal.
Und das hat eigentlich mehr dazu beigetragen fast noch. Also,
wenn die sich anders verhalten hätten, wäre ich vielleicht sogar nicht so entschlossen
gewesen. Aber gerade diese Art und Weise, weil ich weiß, das erste,
was passiert ist, es hat dann irgend so ein ultra rechter Blog die Wohnadresse
meiner Mutter veröffentlicht.
Und die hat dann mal gleich irgendwie Drohbriefe kassiert und ich weiß nicht
was und ist attackiert worden, ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung.
Und das war dann so richtig für mich, na komm, dann lass sehen, dann machen wir.
Weil davor, es war so, ich wäre nicht einmal, ich hatte eigentlich nichts zu
verbergen, ich wäre durchaus bereit gewesen, mit gewissen Behördenstellen zu kooperieren.
Das Problem war, ich habe sehr schnell mitgekriegt, welche Behördenstelle eingesetzt
wurde für die Ermittlungen und ich kannte das Umfeld dieser Behördenstelle gut.
Oder ganz gut zumindest.
Und alles das, was sie halt die Schritte, die sie gesetzt haben,
waren so deutlich für sich sprechend, wenn man Ermittlungen versteht,
dass mir klar war, dass das Ziel offenbar sein würde, mich egal wie fertig zu machen.
Gar nicht so schlecht.
Kommst du auf den Geschmack her?
Auf den Abend.
Na, zu dem Thema braucht man auch...
Also ja, das hilft.
Also du wusstest, wer auf dich angesetzt ist, du hattest Vermutungen.
Ich hatte Vermutungen, die haben sich bestätigt am Ende. Wie gesagt,
es gab, mir war nicht klar.
Und die Ministerien waren ja auch in der Hand.
Naja gut, die Regierung trat zurück. Also der Punkt ist, das Lustige ist,
was wir tatsächlich unterschätzt haben, wir, mich und den Anwalt,
wir haben immer gedacht, die FPÖ ist unser Problem.
Also quasi, wenn wir es schaffen eine Stache zu stürzen und die Regierung irgendwie
zusammenklappt, dann ist unser Problem weg, weil die sind ja nicht mehr in der Regierung.
Und was wir komplett missverstanden hatten, ist, dass die ÖVP,
also die Kurzpartei, mindestens genauso interessiert war, die Sachen so zu belassen, wie sie waren.
Mittlerweile versteht man vielleicht ein bisschen warum, weil die diversen...
Nicht umsonst ist unser Herr Geniekind,
Bundeskanzler Kurz zurückgetreten und ist unter beschuldigten Status und sonst
was, aber es war offenbar die FPÖ nur ein Teil des betreffenden Systems und
wohl der kleinere Teil, wenn man ehrlich ist. Und der wenig professionellere Teil auch.
Und das war eigentlich das Problem. Also unser Problem war dann tatsächlich,
dass eben diese Sonderermittlungseinheit, die sich da bildete,
bildete sich in einer Zeit, wo kein Innenminister da war.
Also was die Polizei hat tatsächlich eigenständig eine SOKO gebildet,
ohne Auftrag einer Staatsanwaltschaft, ohne irgendwas.
Die Regierung tritt zurück, der alte Innenminister geht, der neue ist noch nicht
angelobt, das dauert so circa 36 Stunden. In diesen 36 Stunden geht das Bundeskriminalamt
her und gründet eine SOKO.
Ohne einen Auftrag und besetzt sie mit Beamten von irgendetwas organisierter Kriminalität,
Drogen, Raub, Beamten, die in einer, ok, ich muss jetzt wieder sehr vorsichtig
sein, von der einem gewissen Ruf vorauseilt, sagen wir es mal so.
Die nicht unbedingt normalerweise die klassischen Proponenten für so eine Soko
wären vielleicht auch, also sollen angeblich durchaus auch Dorfpolizisten dabei gewesen sein.
Aber es wird wohl einen Grund haben.
Dürfen die das? Also du sagst, das ist so ungewöhnlich, also es muss normalerweise ein Auftritt geben.
Es muss einen Auftrag geben, also normalerweise kommt eine Staatsanwaltschaft
und sagt, hey, wir haben jetzt vor euch, Staatsanwaltschaft ist die Hüterin,
die Leiterin des Verfahrens.
Das heißt, die Polizei arbeitet für die Staatsanwaltschaft in den Ermittlungsverfahren.
Die Staatsanwaltschaft sagt, wir wollen das machen und die Polizei sagt,
okay, hier ist unsere Einheit X oder Y oder sonst was.
Okay, aber einen Staatsanwalt hat es ja gegeben, aber auch der darf nicht ohne Minister oder so.
Nee, aber die SOKO wurde gegründet, also da war noch kein Akt angelegt oder
sonst irgendwas. Also die haben einfach gesagt, hey, wir werden eine SOKO brauchen
und bevor uns jemand fragt, eine zu machen, weil es gibt nämlich eine Behörde,
die für Korruptionsermittlungen zuständig ist in Österreich,
aber die wollten sie nicht. Sie wollten das Bundeskriminalamt haben.
Was möglicherweise auch seine Gründe hat, aber wie auch immer,
ich will hier nichts unterstellen.
Aber sie haben auch das Bundeskriminalamt gekriegt und das Bundeskriminalamt
hat dann gemacht, was es gemacht hat.
In Exzessivität, wie ich behaupten würde. Also da gab es dann,
weil der Punkt war, die gingen halt davon aus, dass ich der übliche dämliche
Idiot bin, den sie so normalerweise zu tun haben.
Und haben halt so, ja mal keine Ahnung, lassen wir halt TÜs machen und lassen
wir halt da machen und lassen wir halt… Technische Überwachung.
Ja ja, Telefonüberwachungen, lass mal Standortdaten, lass mal historische Nachrichten abfragen etc.
So das übliche Einmaleins, sag ich mal.
Kam ich dabei raus, also es gibt so ganz, ganz kuriose, lustige Seiten im Akt,
wo sie so schreiben, ja der hat irgendein Handy, das kostet 800 Euro,
es ist zu erwarten, dass er also nur die SIM-Karte wechselt und nicht das Telefon, haha.
So in die Richtung gehend. Ist natürlich da nicht passiert, dann haben sie gedacht,
okay gut, wir kommen da nicht weiter.
Aber das lustige ist, sie haben auch nicht versucht, uns zu kontaktieren.
Sie haben eine Anwälte nicht angeschrieben, so quasi einer Vorladung.
Wir haben sie sogar kontaktiert und gesagt, wir bieten euch auch eine Einfahrnahme
im Rechtshilfeweg in Deutschland. Ich komme nur nicht nach Österreich. Keine Chance.
Kein Interesse. Okay. Und dann kam es eben, dann sind sie weitergegangen und
haben sich, da gibt es so etwas lustiges seit 2019, das nennt sich das Institut
der Europäischen Ermittlungsanordnung.
Und ohne jetzt allzu tief einzusteigen, heißt das, dass ein EU-Land einem anderen
EU-Land auftragen kann, eine Ermittlungsmaßnahme durchzuführen,
ohne dass in dem ausführenden Land ein Richter da drauf schaut.
Das heißt, wenn jetzt ein angenommen rumänischer Richter sagt,
er würde gerne die, keine Ahnung was, die Nutte von seinem Cousin in Deutschland
finden und unterschreibt eine europäische Ermittlungsanordnung zu einer Telefonüberwachung
in Düsseldorf, dann wird das gemacht von der deutschen Polizei,
wenn man sich das Richter anschaut.
Echt?
Ja. europäische Ermittlungsanwaltung. In meinem Fall war es dann halt,
dass eine österreichische Staatsanwaltschaft und eine österreichische Ermittlungsrichtung
unterschrieben hat, den Funkzellenabgriff von knapp 130.000 Teilnehmern in Berlin.
Was auch nicht zum Erfolg geführt hat und eigentlich sogar dann nachher auch
in Österreich als rechtswidrig anerkannt wurde.
Hat aber nicht geholfen, weil es war schon mal passiert nochmal.
Und so ging es dahin. Sie haben dann die Funkzellen meiner Anwaltskanzleien abgegriffen.
Bei Sixt haben sie einen Mietwagen, den ich gehabt hatte, sich tatsächlich liefern
lassen nach Österreich und auseinandergebaut, um aus dem Navigationssystem Daten zu ziehen.
Server in Litauen beschlagen haben.
Flughaftsdaten von knapp 6000 Personen aus allen Flügen in dem relevanten Zeitraum
Ibiza in ganz Europa gezogen.
In Klarnamen lustigerweise im Akt, was auch recht geil ist.
Also wir wissen ziemlich genau, wer zwischen dem 23. und 28.
Juni 2017 geflogen ist, falls jemand Interesse hat.
Das waren so die Ermittlungsschritte. Und dann gab es natürlich noch eine ganze
Menge an Hausdurchsuchungen.
Also meine Mutter wurde mehrmals durchsucht und keine Ahnung wer,
jeder Ex-Freundin, die sie gefunden haben von mir wurde durchsucht.
Mit welcher, aber welche Taten haben sie dir denn zulast gelegt?
Ja ursprünglich, das war ja ganz lustig, ursprünglich war eben Ibiza-Video.
Jetzt muss man dazu sagen, in Deutschland gibt es ja im Gesetz festgeschrieben,
das ist überragend der öffentliche Interesse, dass die verdeckte Aufnahme rechtfertigt.
Oder die Veröffentlichung der verdeckten Aufnahme eigentlich.
Das gibt es in Österreich nicht, das wird zwar angewandt, der Grundsatz,
aber steht nicht dezidiert im Gesetz drin.
Diesen Fakt haben sie sich so eingemacht, um ein Strafverfahren wegen Verdeckter
Aufnahme, Weitergabe einer verdeckten Aufnahme zu machen.
Das Punkt war aber, das Problem ist nun mal, die verdeckte Aufnahme hat in Spanien
stattgefunden. In Spanien ist das Rechtssystem anders. In Spanien ist das Rechtssystem
so, dass die verdeckte Aufnahme legal ist, solange man selber auf der verdeckten
Aufnahme drauf ist. Was in dem Fall ja so war.
Wusstet ihr das eigentlich vorher oder war das wie man sieht dich?
Ich bin also der Typ in der weißen Hose am Ibiza-Video, das ist meine Person,
zwar in etwas schlechterer Form damals, aber doch immer ich.
Wusstet ihr das?
Ja, weil mein Partner war Anwalt. Das ist auch etwas, was die Leute missverstehen.
Wir haben das relativ juristisch durchgeprüft vorher.
Also ich bin jetzt nicht hergegangen und hab gesagt, hey komm lass Gesetze brechen, weil ist eh scheißegal,
sondern wir haben gesagt, prüft das juristisch und wir haben da drei verschiedene
Anwälte eingepumpten gehabt,
die zwar nicht gesagt haben, was wir machen wollen, aber die Aktionen,
also die Tathandlungen gesagt haben, die das geprüft haben und alle gesagt haben,
am Ende des Tages wird das legal anerkannt werden müssen, das ist nicht illegal.
Aber da habt ihr ja schnell reagieren müssen, wenn ich mich jetzt richtig erinnere,
diese Ibiza Geschichte kam ja dann verhältnismäßig kurzfristig zustande,
dass der Strache da hinfährt etc., also wieviel Vorlauf.
Das Problem bei der Kurzfristigkeit war jedes Mal eigentlich die Oligarchen.
Also, wie gesagt, mir fällt es ein bisschen schwer, da in diese Teil zu gehen,
aber der Punkt war, dass die halt einerseits nicht wirklich wollte,
also die hatte überhaupt kein Interesse an der Sache, die hat keinen Bock auf
die Sache gehabt, sondern ich hab sie halt begniet mehr oder weniger und hatte
irgendwie einen Gefallen gut bei ihr, der dann aber auch irgendwann raufgebracht war.
Und die hat einfach keinen Bock gehabt. Und das war so jedes Mal so ein,
weiß nicht, wenn du das kennst, wenn du jemanden bittest, der dir irgendwie
hilft und der sagt, ääh, ääh, ääh, und dann zum letzten Mal sagt er, ja komm, ich mach halt.
Und so war es halt dort, also die hat halt dann so 48 Stunden vorher,
habe ich sie dann weichgekocht gehabt, dann habe ich gesagt,
ja komm, mache ich nochmal.
Und da habe ich halt 48 Stunden Zeit gehabt, das irgendwie auf die Beine zu
stellen, was rechtlich knapp ist. Was auch dazu geführt hat,
dass ich dann diese Buchung Villa Ibiza mit Echtkreditkarte getätigt habe.
Weswegen mir auch klar war, dass ich identifizierbar bin.
Was aber auch okay war in meinen Augen, weil tatsächlich ich da Auffassung dann
irgendwann war, dass es sich mittlerweile, Da ging es da ja nicht mehr um Schwarzgeldwaschung
und so klassische Korruptionsdinger, sondern es ging um Wahlmanipulation in Zeiten einer EU-Wahl.
Und da war mir schon klar, dass das andere Interessen wecken würde und ich hab
mir gedacht, tu dir einen Gefallen und schau, dass da jemand,
der wirklich suchen kann und will, was findet.
In diesem 48 Stunden Zeitraum habt ihr dann sozusagen auch noch diesen juristischen Check-up.
Achso, nee, nee, der juristische Check-up, was wir machen wollten, war schon klar.
Nee, ich meine in Bezug auf Spanien, weil das...
Die Spanien hatten wir schon vorher im Radar, also wir wussten schon,
dass Ibiza in Frage kommen würde, ich wusste aber nicht, ob ich die Oligarchin hab.
Okay, verstehe, okay.
Ja, also, ähm, jetzt kam's ja letzt,
also, äh, ne, jetzt im Prinzip hier einmal so,
okay, Ibiza-Video, die Fakten waren, äh,
veröffentlicht, Der Staat hat mehr oder weniger eigenmächtig sozusagen ohne
politische Führung beschlossen, jetzt müssen wir hier mal den Überbringer der
schlechten Botschaft mal ordentlich durch die Mangel nehmen und alles hat sich auf dich fokussiert.
Du hast dich in Deutschland wahrscheinlich auch erstmal verhältnismäßig sicher
gewöhnt, aber auch nicht so zu 100% nehme ich an.
Naja, also der Punkt war, es gab ja tatsächlich, also anfänglich war es ja tatsächlich
nur der Vorwurf der verdeckten Aufnahme, das ist so ein...
Eben, darauf will ich die ganze Zeit hinaus, das ist ja überhaupt gar kein Vorwurf.
Also es ist einer, ich meine, hier auf dem Camp wissen das alle,
aber dass da jetzt ein dermaßener Ermittlungsapparat entsteht,
ist ja schon auch sehr erstaunlich, oder?
Also ja, Ermittlungsdruck ja, aber damit kriegst du halt keine internationale
Rechtshilfe, dafür ist das Delikt einfach zu schwach.
Und was dann passiert ist, sie sind dann dahergekommen, das war dann zu meiner Überraschung,
also ich weiß, ich habe Ibiza veröffentlicht, war dann noch so zwei Wochen im
Lande, also Deutschland in dem Fall, bin dann in einem lang geplanten Urlaub
gefahren, zwar auf etwas komplizierten Wegen, aber nichtsdestotrotz,
kam zurück irgendwann im August 2019 und les in der Zeitung,
Strache ist erpresst worden.
Zug mit der Schulter und denkt man, aha.
Also bringt das nicht zu Zusammenhang. Und das Lustige war, normalerweise hat
es ja Akteneinsicht, das Beschuldigte.
Und in meinem Fall haben sie das zum Geheimakt erklärt, das heißt sie haben
keine Akteneinsicht gewährt.
Das heißt ich wusste eigentlich nicht, was sie mir vorwerfen,
was sie tun, aber was sie gemacht haben ist...
Auch hier muss man wieder vorsichtig sein, aber aus irgendeiner geheimnisvollen
Quelle waren die Zeitungen immer bestens mit Akten gefüttert.
Also im Gegensatz zu mir. Und haben also mir meine Akten quasi veröffentlicht
in den Zeitungen, damit ich weiß, was los ist.
So nett eigentlich.
Eigentlich schon, aber sie haben
es halt immer nur so teilweise veröffentlicht, das war nicht so nett.
Aber wie auch immer und da kam eben die Erpressung und dann war mir klar,
hey, der behauptet, dass ich ihn erpresst habe.
Und für mich war es komplett absurd, weil die ganze Zeit vorher,
über den ganzen Frühsommer hinweg,
laufen die Telefone meiner Anwälte
und aller meiner Bekannten heiß mit irgendwelchen komischen Angeboten,
hey, wir zahlen dir zwei Millionen, drei Millionen für das Video,
sagen nur, dass es der und der in Auftrag gegeben hat, geben uns das Video,
keine Ahnung was, aber es war ein richtig absurder Angebot dabei,
auch teilweise garniert mit schönen Drohungen und sonst was.
Also die wollten unbedingt das Video, warum? Weil am 22.
August kam das Buch dieser Obermeiers auf den Markt, Absipper.
Und der Strache wollte was, was er dem entgegensetzen wollte,
weil der Strache hatte noch immer die Hoffnung, dass er zurückkommen kann.
Der wusste, dass das Buch für ihn natürlich nicht positiv ausfallen wird.
Und er wollte das Video haben, damit er dort seine komischen Sequenzen rausschneiden
kann, wo er sagt, aber es muss alles legal sein.
So wie wenn du an die Bank gehst und sie ausraubst und sagst,
hey ist alles legal, keine Sorge, die Waffe ist echt und ich will dich auch
nicht schießen, aber alles legal.
So ungefähr war der Schmäh, den Herr Strache probiert hat und das wollte er
ihm belegen, deswegen wollte er das Video. Und zwar deswegen wollte er es bis
zum Mitte, Ende August haben.
Und als das nicht kam, Mitte, Ende August, welchen Jahres?
2019, also direkt nachher.
Und als das nicht passiert, geht dann relativ schnell von,
einer FPÖ-nahen, glücksspielnahen Blog eines Glücksspiellobbyisten eine Anzeige
beim Bundeskriminalamt ein,
in der behauptet wird, ich handle Drogen, ich habe den Strache erpresst,
ich bin mit Waffenhandel, ich weiß jetzt so circa 16 ziemlich schwere Paragraphen,
Belegt durch nichts, aber jetzt haben die Behörden die Möglichkeit international tätig zu werden.
Weil jetzt haben sie einen Vorwurf und die Argumentation des Vorwurfs ist,
als sie landen in Strache und fragen im Strache, wo ist der Oppressor? Da sagen sie nein.
Und die Argumentation des Bundeskriminalamts ist, naja, vielleicht schämt er.
Sich es zuzugeben, er könnte ja trotzdem erpresst worden sein,
deswegen ist der Vorwurf glaubwürdig. Geil.
Ziemlich, oder?
Und damit kamen sie dann nach Deutschland, nach Spanien, die Schweiz,
nach Litauen und keine Ahnung, ich glaube es waren so sechs,
sieben europäische Länder, wo sie aktiv geworden sind. Also die waren dann richtig
geil unterwegs, die haben dann so in Malaga ein Büro aufgemacht und irgendwie
Beamte nach Malaga gesetzt, drei Monate lang.
Die wollten auch mal Urlaub machen.
Absoluter Irrsinn.
Ok und damit haben sie sich dann sozusagen… Ja nee,
es kam dann, also das ging dann so weiter, wir haben das natürlich bekämpft,
wir haben dann Beschwerden ohne Ende gemacht, ich hatte dann recht streitlustige
Berliner Anwälte, die da, wie gesagt, die Gepflogenheiten in Österreich nicht
respektiert haben und dann alle angepisst haben mit ihren Schriftsätzen.
Ich hab ne Idee welcher Anwalt das sein könnte.
Ich wollte aber auch in Deutschland den Leuten an… Ich wollte es nicht so ausdrücken,
aber du weißt, wie ich meine Dinge.
Der hat auf der Trauerfeier für Hans-Christian Ströbele das komplette Publikum
beschimpft. Ja, das hört sich schade an.
Das könnte zutreffen. Das gilt die Unschuldsvermutung.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass das juristisch alles astrein war, was der gesagt hat,
aber ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass der eine oder andere...
Ja, nee, er ist ein genialer Jurist, aber er hat eine sehr eigenwillige Art.
Aber die kommt in Österreich nicht so an, meinst du?
Ne, also die haben bis heute ein Verfahren gegen ihn laufen.
Also die haben tatsächlich versucht, die nach Österreich zu einer Verhandlung
zu zitieren und er hat gesagt, geht scheiße, die ist jetzt nicht zuständig für mich.
Aber er meint, er geht nie wieder nach Österreich.
Okay, wie ist denn jetzt so der Stand in diesem Verfahren gegen dich? Also...
Da haben wir es euch jetzt.
Naja, ich bin mir jetzt nicht...
Mich haben wir jetzt schon alles sozusagen erzählt, was jetzt hier relevant ist zur Beurteilung.
Ja, nein. Nein, okay gut, dann... Next.
Dieser Glücksspiel-Lobbyist, von dem, du erinnerst dich, Thomas hat im Logbuch
noch einiges von diesem Glücksspiel-Lobbyisten und dem sich dann anschließend
ein Verfahren erzählt, denn, so viel sei gesagt, Julian wurde verurteilt.
Ja, also dieser Glücksspiel-Lobbyist hat also Anzeigen angebracht gegen mich
ohne Ende und seinen Blog quasi damit befeuert, dass er behauptet hat,
über ihn sei die Information zur Verfügung.
Was er tatsächlich gemacht hat, er hat sich also zwei ehemalige freie Mitarbeiter
meiner Firma damals an die Hand genommen, die sich angeboten haben,
gegen Geld die mit Informationen zu liefern.
Diese Informationen waren zum großen Teil einfach erfunden und falsch.
Das hat ihn aber nicht gestört, weil er wollte eigentlich nur möglichst nachteilige
Informationen veröffentlichen können.
Und so hat er halt dann quasi, je nachdem wie man es jetzt sieht,
aber behaupten wir mal die freundliche Variante, Justiz vor sich her getrieben,
indem er quasi Exklusiv-Stories veröffentlicht hat, die dann sogar bis zu großen
deutschen Leitmedien seine Infos übernommen haben teilweise und behauptet hat,
er hat halt irgendwie Zugänge, Informationen, Exklusivquellen,
die behaupten, ich wäre im Waffenhandel tätig, hätte an einem Attentat mitgewirkt,
hätte Zuhälter gewesen, hätte Drogen gehandelt, hätte eine Handplantage gehabt,
hätte keine Ahnung was, also schon ziemlich rauf und runter das Gesetzbuch und
hat das unterfüttert mit angeblichen Belegen, die die ihm geliefert haben.
Und einer dieser Belege nur zum Beispiel war das Bild einer Hanfplantage,
das er beim Bundeskanalamt eingereicht hat, wo er gesagt hat,
das ist eine Hanfplantage, die steht in Salzburg und die wird von Julian Hessenthaler betont.
Und das BKA hat es sich dann also hergenommen und weil diese Leute da um diesen
Glücksspiel-Lobbyisten nun mal technisch nicht die intelligentesten Jungs sind,
haben sie halt die Metadaten nicht gelöscht.
Und kam halt irgendwie raus, okay das Ganze ist irgendwie runtergeladen von
der badischen Zeitung von 2013 und zeigt eine Plantage, die irgendwie 2013 hochgenommen wurde.
Und kann also irgendwie schwerlich mit mir in Zusammenhang stehen.
Und dann passiert was Lustiges.
Dann ermittelt also das Bundeskriminalamt tatsächlich wegen Betrug gegen diese
zwei anderen ehemaligen freien Mitarbeiter von mir. Und das Opfer ist dieser Lobbyist.
Nicht du!
Nein, das Opfer ist der Lobbyist, weil sie haben ja von ihm Geld genommen.
Sie haben ihn betrogen, indem sie ihm falsche Informationen verkauft haben.
Moment, Moment. So, jetzt durchsucht, aufgrund, jetzt hört das Bundeskriminalamt
also diese zwei Idioten ab, diese ehemaligen freien Mitarbeiter von mir,
die gleichzeitig auch V-Leute derselben Abteilung des Bundeskriminalamts sind,
aus der ich so gekommen bin.
Langsam, es wird besser.
Diese V-Leute unterhalten sich also auf offenen Telefonen, weil sie sich sicher
wehnen, weil V-Leute des Bundeskriminalamts über Drogenhandel, den sie betreiben.
Das BKA hört also jetzt drei Monate lang den Koks-Deals dieser Leute zu.
Und beschließt dann, hey wir müssen eine Hausdurchsuchung bei denen machen,
weil es geht nicht mehr. Das Problem war, das ist ein glamouröser Akt,
wie das in Österreich heißt, das heißt der muss zur Ministerebene raufgetragen werden, zur Absegnung.
Was das Bundeskriminalamt normalerweise sonst gemacht hätte,
es hätte einfach seine V-Leute wahrscheinlich gedeckt, behaupte ich jetzt mal,
es gibt die Unschuldsvermutung.
Und hätte einfach nichts gemacht. Aber es geht halt jetzt nun mal nicht,
es ist zu hoch angesiedelt. Wir müssen also eine Hausdurchsuchung machen.
Und jetzt kommt der Witz an der Sache. Die hören also drei Monate lang Telefone
ab, wo die irgendwie darüber diskutieren, hey ich brauche noch 30 Linien und
hast du noch weißes Papier übrig und keine Ahnung, so supergeile Codes.
Und das Bundeskriminalamt geht also jetzt und sagt, hey wir brauchen Sondereinsatzkommando
Cobra und keine Ahnung was, weil die sind vielleicht bewaffnet und ich weiß
nicht was. Was sie auch waren.
Und der Durchsuchungsbefehl ist ausgestellt wegen Betrug. Also sie durchsuchen
nicht wegen dem Drogenhandel,
den sie drei Monate abgehört haben, sondern sie durchsuchen wegen dem angeblichen
Betrug gegen diesen Lobbyisten, finden bei der Freundin des einen 130 Gramm
Koks in einem Staubsaugerbeutel.
Langsam.
Das raucht man ja auch mal schnell weg.
Ich sag ja, Österreich ist speziell. Ne, warte, warte, es wird besser.
Noch besser.
Staubsaugerbeutel, 130 Gramm Koks. Ne, also diese Freundin, die sagt,
wem gehört das Koks? Sie sagt, das kommt von irgendeinem Albaner.
Okay, dann setzen sie sich irgendwie und sagen, ich glaub dir nicht,
wem gehört das Koks? Okay, es gehört meinem Freund. Woher hat das von Ihnen, Maribana?
Durchsuchen diesen Freund, der ist ein ehemaliger Mitarbeiter von mir,
finden dort irgendwie 10 Gramm Koks, eine Menge Waffen und sonstigen Schwachsinn
und irgendeine geile, weil er einfach ein Genie ist, eine Aufstellung von seinen
Ausgaben die letzten paar Monate, die so circa sich auf 30.000 Euro im Monat
belaufen für Philipp Plein und keine Ahnung was für Scheiße.
Der hat eine Rolle gespielt in unserem Vortrag gestern. Philipp Plein, das ist der Crypto King.
Nee, der komische Designer-Ding da.
Ja, ja, der Designer. Ja klar, mit so'n Pizza-Schuh.
Ja, genau, genau.
14.000 Euro Schuhe. Ja, ja, genau.
Von dem hat er Schuhe gekauft.
Jetzt wissen wir endlich, wer bei dem kauft. Aber Kantorkel wusste das eh schon vorher.
Ja, nee, also gut, also...
Wir haben ja die Verkaufsbox. Sag mal, wann die da eingekauft haben. Guck mal mal.
Die Welt ist so schlecht.
Wir haben die Glocks gehabt.
Da ist ein Akt drin. Kannst du rausholen, wenn du willst. Nee,
aber jedenfalls, okay, gut, die durchsuchen den auch.
Der sagt, Ja, das Koks ist für den Eigenbedarf die 130 Gramm,
weil seine Freundin hatte keine Ahnung von woher kommen, weiß er nicht. Mein Name fällt nicht.
Dann passiert was Kurioses. Das BKA, die das in Salzburg die Durchsuchung gemacht
hat, mit Salzburger Einsatzkräften, setzt also diese Freundin von dem Typen
in ein Auto und überstellt sie nach Wien.
Separat von ihm. Und laut dem Akt, man weiß es jetzt nicht, weil es ist leider
nicht protokolliert, dauert diese Überstellung sieben Stunden lang.
Der Fahrtweg Wien Salzburg ist circa zweieinhalb bis drei Stunden je nachdem.
In diesen sieben Stunden ist protokolliert, es wurden mehrere Pausen gemacht, fertig, Punkt.
In diesen Pausen wurden informelle Gespräche geführt, fertig,
Punkt. Sie kommt in Wien an, in Wien auf einmal ist ihre Aussage,
das Koks kommt von mir und ich habe noch viel mehr geliefert und nicht von einem Albaner.
Er bestreitet das, er sagt, das stimmt alles nicht. Und sie sagt auf einmal,
ja, wir haben sechs Kilo Koks verkauft und irgendwie ein Kilo kommt vom Julian.
Die Polizei fragt nicht, woher die anderen fünf Kilo kommen sollen,
sie sagt nur, wirklich vom Julian? Ja, vom Julian. Okay.
Die Polizei fragt ihn, er sagt, nee, stimmt alles nicht, alles Blödsinn,
sie redet irgendeinen Schwachsinn.
Sie macht dann im Laufe, die gehen dann beide in die Untersuchungshaft, ewig lange, ca.
Neun Monate später ist ihr Prozess. In diesen neun Monaten macht sie elf Aussagen
bei der Polizei und in jeder dieser Aussagen sagt sie was anderes.
Also nämlich so was kausal anderes. Also es ist irgendwann 2017 gewesen,
nee es war irgendwann 2018, es war Sommer, es war Winter, es war Linz,
es war Salzburg, also man weiß es nicht.
Jede Aussage differenziert von der nächsten.
Sie hat mich bedroht, ich habe sie bedroht, man ganz, also wie auch immer. Die gehen vor Gericht.
Sie wird vor Gericht von der Richterin befragt und zwar normalerweise vor Gericht
ist es normal, dass man quasi zu den Vorwürfen gefragt wird.
Das heißt, der Richter wird fragen, okay, die Staatsanwaltschaft behauptet,
dass sie tralala in ihrer Aussage haben sie das und das gesagt, was trifft zu.
Die Richterin in dem Fall tut das nicht, weil die Richterin in dem Fall noch
nie ein Strafverfahren geführt hat. Die Richterin will den Fall auch nicht,
sie versucht ihn dreimal abzugeben, aber sie wird auch auferlegt. Warum auch immer.
Und in diesem Verfahren nimmt die Richterin den Strafantrag der Staatsanwaltschaft,
liest ihn vor und fragt, sie stimmt das.
Und die sagt ja, ja, ja, Ja, ja, ja. Fertig. Er sagt nein, nein, nein, nein.
Sie bekommt für den zugegebenen Verkauf und Handel von knapp,
glaube ich, dreieinhalb Kilo Kokain sechs Monate fix und zwölf Monate auf Bewährung
aufgebunden mit einer Vorstrafe wegen Drogen schon?
Erstaunlich, also das hat noch nie jemand gehört, glaube ich.
Er bekommt drei Jahre, weil er nicht zugibt.
Dann passiert was ganz kurioses, drei Tage später taucht sein Freund und andere
ehemalige Mitarbeiter, die er nicht verhaftet wurde wegen Drogenhandel beim
Staatsanwalt auf und sagt, er möchte etwas zu Protokoll geben.
Sein Freund, der jetzt drei Jahre bekommen hat, hat gelogen vorher und er weiß,
das stimmt eigentlich, dass ich schon die Drogen geliefert habe.
Daraufhin geht der Staatsanwaltschaft zu dem Typen, der jetzt sitzt mit drei Jahren.
Es gibt wieder informelle Gespräche laut dem Akt mit dem Bundeskriminalamt,
man weiß nicht, was geredet wird.
Und dann stellt dieser Typ mit seinen drei Jahren Strafe einen Antrag bei der
Staatsanwaltschaft, ob er denn die elektronische Fußfessel bekommen könnte,
wenn er seine Aussage ändert.
Schriftlich.
Die Staatsanwaltschaft schreibt natürlich formell korrekt richtig zurück.
Wir versprechen nichts, je nachdem, wir werden es sehen.
Er ändert seine Aussage, er sagt, nee, nee, ich hab vorher gelogen,
es stimmt doch, ich hab Angst gehabt vor ihm, aber er hat mir die Drogen verkauft.
Ein Monat später geht er auf Fußfessel nach Hause.
Und am Ende dieser ganzen Aussage-Geschichte waren die so halbwegs frei oder
zumindest nicht mehr ganz so eingesperrt und die ganze Last lag auf dir.
Ja, weil sie haben bei so neun Monaten U-Haft, die Freundin von ihm hat sechs
Monate bekommen, damit war sie schon erledigt, nach dem Urteil nach Hause gegangen.
Gegangen. Er hat, nachdem er seine Aussage geändert hat, die Fußfessel beantragen
können, hat er also knapp ein Jahr abgesessen von den drei Jahren.
Urhaft. Deswegen. So, jetzt haben Sie also zwei Aussagen korrelierend,
dass ich Drogen verkauft habe an Sie angeblich.
Die passen noch immer nicht ganz zusammen, aber wie auch immer,
es reicht für einen Haftbefehl jetzt offenbar.
Da wird uns aber nichts gesagt. Also der Punkt ist jetzt, wir kontaktieren monatlich
die deutsche Polizei, die deutsche Generalstaatsanwaltschaft in Berlin,
als auch die österreichische Polizei, sagen, hey, gibt es einen Haftbefehl?
Wenn ja, da stellt sich auch kein Problem, nur nicht in Österreich. Sagen wir euch nicht.
Wollt ihr ihn vorladen? Nee. Okay. In der Zwischenzeit bin ich irgendwo in Spanien
unterwegs. Bin gerade irgendwie mit dieser Wirecut-Show ein bisschen beschäftigt. und dann...
Kommt eine Durchsuchung des Ferienhauses meiner Mutter in Frankreich durch eine
Europol-Spezialeinheit.
Womit mir relativ klar ist, ok, wenn eine Europol-Spezialeinheit da irgendwie
ausrückt, dann muss ein Haftbefehl irgendwo liegen, das geht sonst nicht.
Reden meine Anwälte, die meinen, hey, komm zurück nach Berlin,
besser für dich, weil in Berlin zumindest können wir dich halbwegs rechtlich schützen.
Komme also nach Berlin, Zeiten von Corona, verschlungene Wege, kompliziert.
Und setz mich mal in Berlin hin und mach tatsächlich das, was ich immer gemacht
hab, das heißt ich geh zu meiner Hausbank, einmal die Woche,
tätige Geschäfte am Bankgestalter mit Ausweis, geh auf Krankenkarte zum Arzt
für irgendwie so Standarduntersuchungen, warte, ob was passiert, es passiert nichts.
Also tatsächlich recht erstaunlich, wie ich nachher wusste, habe ich einen Interpol-Haftbefehl
gehabt, aber offenbar kann man auch mit dem Interpol-Haftbefehl bei der Sparkasse
Berlin am Alexanderplatz ohne Probleme Bankgeschäfte tätigen.
Dann kommt irgendwann also der Zugriff. Ich merke, dass eine Observation rennt,
die ich, ohne es jetzt in Detail gehen zu wollen, aus diversen Gründen nicht...
Also ich hätte die Observation wahrscheinlich entgehen können,
als Problem wäre dadurch ein anderes Problem entstanden.
Ich denke mir, es hat keinen Sinn mehr, komm lass. Schauen wir mal was passiert.
Packen Patzen Geld ein, packen ein frisches Handy ein, packen ein USB-Regal
ein, frisch gewipen und gehen mal spazieren.
Und werden dann auch vom BKA Wiesbaden verhaftet. In Berlin.
Tatsächlich Hintergrund dessen ist, dass die Berliner Polizei,
laut der österreichischen Polizei, die Berliner Polizei wird das natürlich dementieren
nehme ich an, aber ich bin trotzdem ganz dankbar, sich angeblich geweigert hat,
irgendwie zu kooperieren, nach diesen Funkzellenabgriffen.
Also zumindest nicht sonderlich aktiv war.
Und deswegen das Bundeskriminalamt in Österreich ihre Kollegen in Wiesbaden
gebeten haben, ob sie denn nicht irgendwie behilflich sein wollen könnten.
Und die waren dann auch behilfreich und haben mich also im Prenzlauer Berg dann
verhaftet, am 10. Dezember 2020.
Haben mich noch Moabit über, also das heißt Tempelhof, glaube ich,
ist das bei euch, das Polizeianhaltezentrum, oder?
Berlin.
Der Knast in Berlin?
Ja, das Polizeieinheitersendung ist Tempelhof. Moabit ist das Gefängnis,
aber davor gibt es das komische Pool. Also wie auch immer, ich komme nach Moabit.
Ich würde nie zugeben, das schon mal gewesen zu sein.
Ja, also wie auch immer, ich komme nach Moabit, bin dann dort irgendwie so knapp dreieinhalb Monate,
bekämpfe die Auslieferungsstellen, Asylantrag sogar in Deutschland,
gehe zum Bundesverfassungsgericht, Weil sich die Berliner Gerichte weigern,
die Auslieferung hinsichtlich politischer Verfolgung zu prüfen?
Verliere alle Varianten, also auch beim Bundesverfassungsgericht und wer dann
zum Wirecard-Untersuchungsausschuss geladen, lustigerweise, im Bundestag.
Direkt aus dem Knast sozusagen. Ja.
Wird tatsächlich mit dem Justizbuch zum Bundestag gefahren, in Handschellen
und wurde in Handschellen in den Bundestag reingeführt, in den U-Ausschussraum des Bundestags.
Können wir ganz kurz einen Exkurs zu Wirecard machen oder führt das jetzt zu weit?
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sich jemand dafür interessiert.
Ja, der Punkt dahinter war, dass Wirecard, wenn man sich da beschäftigt,
eine ziemlich österreichische Angelegenheit ist.
Ich hatte tatsächlich einen Seitenhaus. Wie ist das? Wird in Österreich auch
nicht so gesehen oder so ähnlich wie Deutschland muss überfallen.
Hat Wirecut in Österreich noch nichts mit Österreich zu tun?
Es waren immer die Deutschen. Es waren immer die Deutschen.
Der Punkt ist, dass ich mich mit dem Seitenaspekt von Wirecut beschäftigt,
der mir zufällig irgendwie über den Weg gelaufen ist, diese Libyen-Geschichte,
Söldnertruppenaufbau.
Und hatte da irgendwie ein paar Linien verfolgt, was mitunter auch mal ein Grund
für meinen Aufenthalt in Spanien war, unter anderem.
Aber ja, wie auch immer, also das war dann, ich hatte also so ein paar,
in Wirklichkeit wahrscheinlich konnte ich ein paar Vermutungen,
die der Untersuchungsausschuss hatte, bestätigen.
Ich konnte jetzt keine sonderlich neuen Aspekte glaube ich hinzufügen,
ich konnte vielleicht ein paar Einblicke aus österreichischer Perspektive gewähren
und auch vielleicht ein paar bekannte Gerüchte bestätigen oder dementieren hier und da.
Das war es im Prinzip. Das Lustige an der Geschichte ist, ich erwähne es deswegen,
weil die österreichische Krankenwacht versucht
haben, einen Auftritt im Wirecard-Untersuchungsausschuss zu verhindern.
Der Punkt dahinter war, dass es in der europäischen Rechtsgeflogenheit üblich
ist, dass die Auslieferung, selbst wenn sie bekämpft wird, maximal drei Monate dauern darf.
Mein Auftritt im Bundestag war exakt, ich glaube, drei Monate und eine Woche
später angesetzt. Die Österreicher haben darauf bestanden, mich auszuliefern.
Der Bundestag hat gesagt, nee, wir wollen den Laden erst zeigen.
Die Österreicher haben gesagt, nee, das geht nicht, ihr habt drei Monate Frist,
ihr müsst den ausliefern. Nee, wir wollen den Laden erst zeigen,
nee, das geht nicht. Hinher, hinher, hinher.
Bis die Österreicher gesagt haben, hey, wenn ihr nicht den ausliefert,
dann zahlen wir die Auslieferung nicht. Weil normalerweise muss immer das Land,
in das du ausgeliefert bist, die Rechnung übernehmen.
Und der Bundestag hat dann sagen, müsst ihr ja gut, dann zahlen wir's.
Also meine Auslieferung nach Österreich wurde aus Bundestagsbudget gezahlt,
weil sonst wäre es nicht möglich gewesen. Nur um zu verdeutlichen,
wie sehr den Österreichern es wichtig war, dass ich nicht dort meinen Mund öffnen kann.
Ja, dann wurde ich also nach Wien überstellt. Wien war dann auch,
ja, mein Gott, von allen Gefängnissen, wo ich war, war Moabit mit Sicherheit
das Beste und mir sagen alle Leute, Moabit ist richtig scheiße.
In wieviel Gefängnissen warst du denn schon?
Jetzt drei. Also Moabit, Wien und dann bin ich tatsächlich nach St.
Pölten verlegt worden zu meiner Verhandlung.
Bin also auf Wien überstellt. Wien ist Einzelhaft, ist Sicherheitsabteilung,
ist also die Abteilung, wo irgendwie alle IS-Terroristen, Mörder und sonst was eingebracht sind.
Und noch dazu dann dort in Einzelhaft, weil Sicherheitsbedenken geäußert werden,
bin dann dort knappe dreieinhalb Monate oder so in Einzelhaft,
was relativ anstrengend für den Kopf ist, also irgendwie ungesund,
Einzelhaft kann man nicht empfehlen.
Merkt euch das.
Nein, nein, nein. Du brauchst keines, kannst abschalten und so,
aber danach wird's anstrengend.
Ähm...
Und...
Schaffst mich aus der Einzelhaft rauszulösen, indem ich der Anstalt schriftlich
meine Einwilligung gebe, mich auf eigenes Risiko in die Generalpopulation zu überstellen.
Generalpopulation der Sicherheitsabteilung, so weit gesagt.
War sogar ganz gut, sobald ich in die Generalpopulation war.
War eigentlich ganz vergleichsweise angenehm, soweit Gefängnishalten angenehm sein können.
Also mit den anderen Häftlingen zusammen heißt das?
Ja, also du bist schon noch immer, aber du bist jetzt nicht mehr einer,
also davor war ich separiert, ich hatte so eine Zelle, die keine Ahnung,
was weiß ich was, so zwölf Quadratmeter groß war oder so, und da geht halt tatsächlich
die Klappe auf, du kriegst alles in die Klappe gezogen, das war's.
Also es hieß kein Arsch, und danach warst du halt in einer Zelle mit anderen
Leuten, das ist zwar nicht immer angenehm, aber zumindest irgendwie,
also ein Mensch ist ein Herdentier am Ende des Tages, und wenn du lange irgendwie
separiert gehalten wirst, dann fährt einfach dein Organismus zurück.
Du merkst einfach, der Kopf wird langsamer, du wirst dumpf, du wirst apathisch,
du hast Schlafstörungen.
Es ist, wie gesagt, nicht zu empfehlen einfach.
Folter, oder? Also ich meine, es ist doch schon hardcore, oder?
Was soll denn das bringen?
Ja, Folter, ich meine, ich bin immer… Ja, ja, also es ist wohl schon… Die Methodik
mag schon Folter und Methodik haben, aber ich bin immer vorsichtig mit diesen
Foltersachen, weil tatsächlich gibt's Leute, die…
Also ich hab Leute auch sogar bei mir im Gefängnis gehabt, ich hab's Jürgen
gehabt, die haben Narben am Rücken gehabt.
Also steigerungsfähig ist das, aber es ist da nochmal...
Das ist üblich, wenn man so vorstig mit Freunden vorgeht.
Ja, aber ich meine, wenn das Hauptziel ist, jemanden erstmal der Öffentlichkeit
zu entziehen, dann muss man ja nicht gleich...
Nee, man muss sagen...
Der Deutsche Bundestag, speziell die SPD, hat Bedenken geäußert nach meinem
Auftritt im U-Ausschuss und hat Bedenken gegenüber der österreichischen Justiz
geäußert und auch Sicherheitsbedenken.
Die Österreicher haben das dann hergenommen als Grund mich in den Einzellauf
zu nehmen, aus diesen geäußerten Sicherheitsbedenken.
Was ihnen natürlich entgegengekommen sein mag, aber nichtsdestotrotz,
ich kann ihnen jetzt nicht den Vorwurf formell machen, dass sie mich quasi als Bestrafung...
Also wann ist wieder die Deutschen schuld?
Was haben die Deutschen für Sicherheitsbedenken geäußert? Guter Zeuge,
aber ansonsten gefährlich oder was?
Nee, nee, ungefährlich. Nee, das ist um seine Person, sie haben Bedenken gehabt
um deine Sicherheit und deswegen haben sie sich...
Achso, um dich zu beschützen.
Dem passiert hier nix. Da passen wir auf. Da machen wir hier ein Netz.
Gott.
So und dann kam auf einmal aus dem heiteren, aus dem Blauen heraus,
die Anklage wird in St. Polten stattfinden, nicht in Wien.
Komplett unsinnig war, weil also Wien war die ganze Zeit, Staatsanwaltschaft
Wien war damit befasst, es gab keine Anbindung an St. Pölten,
St. Pölten muss man dazusagen gilt in Österreich so als relativ rückständiges,
rechtsorientiertes...
Also was meinst du mit St. Pölten ist ein Ort?
Ist ein Ort, Provinzhauptstadt, also so wie, keine Ahnung, Bayern und München
die Hauptstadt ist, St. Pölten die Hauptstadt von Niederösterreich.
Niederösterreich gilt halt generell so vielleicht ein bisschen so rechtslastig
vielleicht, konservativ oder wie auch immer.
St.
Pölken ist nochmal so ein spezielles Pflaster darin gehend und auch das Gerichtdienst
in St. Pölken gilt da sehr polizeinah.
Also es gibt das Gerücht unter den Anwälten in Österreich schon,
dass wenn die Polizei was anklagen will, wo sie wenig Beweise hat,
aber gerne eine Verurteilung hätte, geht sie nach St. Pölken damit.
Wie auch immer, Sankt Pölken war ausgerufen,
meine Anwälte haben gesagt, wenn du in Sankt Pölken angeklagt wirst,
wirst du verurteilt, keine Chance,
bekämpfen wir das, wir haben es bekämpft, wir haben es wie immer verloren,
kam nach Sankt Pölken, dort komplett andere Show, also hab wieder erwartet,
ok jetzt fängt die Einzelhaft an und so weiter, wieder gleiche Geschmähe, nein, überhaupt nicht,
war das komplett egal, sie haben mich da reingeholt, da nehmt alle Sachen, geht da eine.
Gefängnisse sind es üblich, dass man nach Nationalität und nach Religionsbekenntnis
zusammengelegt wird, also war logisch, dass man mit Österreichern zusammengelegt werden würde.
In meinem Fall war die Kuriosität der Auswahl der Zelle dahingehend zu sehen,
dass die anderen Insassen der
Zelle allesamt wegen irgendwelchen Hass und Neonazi oder wie sagt man so,
Wiederbetätigung heißt es in Österreich, also quasi rückfällige Nazi-Verbrechen
in irgendeiner Form verurteilt waren, also der Einschlag war deutlich,
sagen wir es mal so, also die Hakenkreuzchen an den Betten auch.
Warum auch immer, kann sein, dass es Zufall ist, kann auch einfach sein,
dass irgendjemand gedacht hat, hey das ist lustig, weiß ich nicht.
War halt nichts anderes frei vielleicht.
So hat man es mir auch gesagt. Wie auch immer,
also da wurde nicht sonderlich viel Wert auf jetzt diese Sicherheitsbedenken
gelegt offenbar, war aber auch eigentlich kein Problem, weil tatsächlich wie
ich drauf gekommen bin im Gefängnis, wenn so das Gefühl herrscht,
du hast quasi den Staat gefickt, dann bist du einfach geil.
Äh... Echt jetzt?
Gesteigerter Coolness-Faktor sozusagen.
Ja, also ist zwar wirklich, das kann ich wirklich nicht beschweren.
Weil alle immer so gemeint haben, hey, bist du bedroht?
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Die Leute haben mir Kuchen gebacken.
Im Knast?
Echt? Da kann man einfach so Kuchen backen? Aber haben die auch einen Ofen?
Nee, hast du nicht. Aber ich hab's sogar selber gelernt. Nicht schlecht erklärt.
Im Knast kannst du dir ausleihen, das geht in Deutschland übrigens nicht.
Das einzige Nachteil, im Moabit musst du das tatsächlich bauen mit irgendwelchen
Thunfischdosen und Tocht und Öl in der Dose.
Nee, du kannst dir Kochplatten ausborgen. Und wenn du jetzt zwei Kochplatten
nimmst und zwei Pfannen hast und die quasi gegenverkehrt übereinanderlegst,
kannst du einen Ofen bauen.
Und wenn du dann noch weißt, wie du einen Biskuitteig anrührst,
was eigentlich nicht so schwierig ist, Da kannst du tatsächlich Kuchenformen
backen und ich habe tatsächlich am Ende vierstöckige Torten gebacken. Also kein Spiel.
Echt, die rückfälligen Nazis haben dir einen Kuchen gebacken?
Nee, das waren die rumänischen Einbacker.
Achso. Untertitel im Auftrag des ZDF für funk, 2018,
Alter, die Nummer hat sich schon gelohnt. Die Geschichten, die du erzählen kannst,
den Rest des Lebens einfach unbezahlbar.
Nee, die Nazis wollten mich mit dir zu Bamen füttern.
Aber dann machen wir morgen mal einen Kuchen zusammen.
Ja, können wir machen.
Zwei Kochplatten haben wir.
Geht super easy. Kommt gut raus.
Wie heißt noch Red Bull da für dich?
Jaja, ich war gerade besorgt.
Also dafür, dass du keinen Red Bull trinkst, wollte ich gerade sagen, mach dich fest.
Das ist die Österreichisierung jetzt, ne?
Jetzt verstehst du, womit der Martin Schmitt seinen Fußballklub gezeigt hat.
Ja, so läuft es.
Die sind alle durch dieses Getränk paralysiert.
Ja, damit wird Leipzig gezeigt. Und Salzburg.
Und Salzburg. Gibt es noch geile Knastrezepte? Ja, ja, Knastrezepte gibt es eine Menge.
Ich habe auch ein paar, die sind sehr gut. Ich habe auch ein paar,
die sind sehr gut. Gibt's noch geile Knastrezepte?
Ja, ja, ja, Knastrezepte gibt's eine Menge. Also ich hab' Kebabs gemacht,
es gibt im Knastes Essen, anstaunlich schlechte, was es gibt ab und an,
so einmal im Monat, ist Kochfleisch, anstaunlich beschissen.
Aber wenn du's trocknest, kleinschneidest, marinierst und abbratest,
dann hast du sowas ähnliches wie Kebabfleisch tatsächlich.
Wie war's denn schon?
Kebabfleisch.
Kebab?
Döner heißt das?
Döner.
Ah!
Sorry.
Ja, nee.
Österreich. Nee, es geht gut. Es ist enormer Aufwand.
Ich hab dann angefangen Fleisch einzutauschen. Ich hab dann tatsächlich meinem
Stock angeboten, dass ich die Wäsche prioritär wasche, weil ich war in der Wäscherei
dann nachher angestellt. Ich hab gesagt, wenn ihr eure Wäsche wirklich schnell
und sauber haben wollt, Fleisch bei mir.
Ist das auch so, dass ihr mit Alkohol selber braut, dass da dann Hefen gehandelt werden oder so?
Aber es ist, weil ich meine, die Leute machen so die absurden Sachen im Gefängnis,
die hauen sich Sachen rein, die du nicht einmal, also da werden Medikamente
missbraucht in einem Umfang, den du noch nie gesehen hast.
Und Sachen gespritzt durch Kugelschreiber, nee, es gibt echt,
ich muss sagen, es ist einfach nur unappetitlich.
Ok, wir bleiben nur... also Kuchen.
Das ist ja eine Familiensendung, da müssen wir ein bisschen vorsichtig sein.
Alles gut. Ne, also wie gesagt, das war so die Zeit dann in St.
Pölken. Mir war schon dann Prozessbeginn, der Prozess hat irgendwie sieben Monate
lang gedauert, waren x-fache Termine. Der Prozess lief ganz witzig, weil...
Mir war eigentlich klar, ich
wäre verurteilt und meine Anwälte haben so teilweise noch gesagt, hey ...
Ich mein, das Ding da stand doch auf dünnen, also Töne an den Füßen ist ja sozusagen
noch eine Übertreibung. Das ist ja eher so eine semipermeable Membran,
auf der das Ganze aufgebaut ist.
Ja nee, aber das Lustige ist, ich mein, dass ich das als subjektiv Betroffener
sage, ist logisch. Aber wir haben da tatsächlich, also was da tatsächlich war
und dafür bin ich auch ganz dankbar, gab's diverse NGOs, unter anderem Epicenter
Works, die jetzt eh auch da sind.
Thomas.
Die dann tatsächlich sich die Mühe gemacht haben, nachdem wir ihnen den Akt
zur Verfügung gestellt haben, den Akt durchzuschauen.
Weil wir halt allen gesagt haben, hey, das ist komplett absurd,
das ist kafkaesk. Und die Journalisten haben halt alle gesagt,
hey, das ist die Staatsanwaltschaft, die wird jetzt nicht irgendwer was zusammenfantasieren,
die wird schon was haben, wenn sie sich anklagt. Wir haben gesagt,
hey, die haben gar nichts, das ist kompletter Bullshit.
Aber es war halt ein 50.000 Seiten Akt und die Journalisten sind halt nun mal
Journalisten und ein bisschen faul oft.
Vor allem, das ist jetzt nicht mehr die große Story, ob ich jetzt verurteilt werde oder nicht,
das ist jetzt nicht mehr Ibiza-Video, wo man irgendwie eine ganze Redaktion
dran setzt, Tag und Nacht, so a la Obermeier-Secret, das Geheimerkämmerchen
in der SS, sondern das ist halt, ja ok, geht er ins Gefängnis oder nicht,
mein Gott, setzen wir halt einen lokalen Journalisten drauf an.
Und die haben sich halt tatsächlich den Mühe gemacht, den Akt durchzuarbeiten
und sind halt so im selben Schluss gekommen und sind dann nachher,
glaube ich mit 18, 19, 20 anderen NGOs public gegangen, einen Tag vor Prozessbeginn,
unter anderem mit Amnesty International und haben gesagt, hier der Prozess stinkt.
Das passt hinten und vorne nicht zusammen. Wir haben uns das angeschaut und das macht keinen Sinn.
Die Orte, die Zeiten, die ist alles so irgendwie. Im Endeffekt,
die Anklage war, der hat irgendwann 2017, 2018 irgendwo in Österreich bei drei
Gelegenheiten Kokain übergeben. Mit einer Gesamtmenge von 1,25 Kilo.
Es ist nicht mehr möglich festzustellen, wo genau und wann genau.
Aber wir haben Zeugen, die das prinzipiell bestätigen, den Vorwurf.
Nachdem sie schon 20 andere Geschichten erzählt haben.
Das schon, aber der Punkt ist, normalerweise brauchst du für einen Tatvorwurf
einen Tatort, eine Tatzeit, irgendwas.
Da waren zwei, und das Lustige war, wir hatten auch noch Beweise gefunden,
dass die Geld kassiert hatten.
Es gab E-Mail-Verkehr eben, dass dieser besagte Glücksspiel-Lobbyist,
der Novomatic, das ist so in Österreich, die wird lustigerweise,
um das zu verstehen, warum die Novomatic jetzt irgendwie relevant wäre,
und warum die sich da irgendwie einmischen sollte, weil was hat ein Glücksspielkonzern mit Ibiza zu tun?
Hochreguliert, oder?
Hochreguliert, ja. Es gab also offenbar Lobbying, die Glücksspielgesetze zu
ändern unter der Strache-Regierung, das ja. Aber warum dezidiert Novomatic?
Weil der Strache in einem der wenigen veröffentlichten Sequenzen des Ibiza-Videos,
die die SZ veröffentlicht hat...
Der hat sie alle. Der zahlt sie alle.
Richtig. Da sagt er, die Novomatic zahlt alle. Und das war natürlich ein unglaublicher
Nachteil für die Novomatic, das sind Strafverfahren eingeleitet worden und Ermittlungsverfahren
und sonst was. Und die Novomatic ist dafür bekannt, dass sie mit äußerst harten
Bandagen kämpft, wenn sie unter Druck kommt.
Deswegen, das ist jetzt kein Beweis, und die Novomatic bestreitet das auch,
muss man dazu sagen. Die Novomatic hat immer von sich gewiesen,
dass sie je irgendwas damit zu tun hatte. Sie hat überhaupt kein Interesse an mir.
Auffällig ist, dass dieser Lobbyist, der übrigens mittlerweile kurioserweise
in einem anderen Verfahren wegen Anstiftung zu falscher Zeugenaussage verurteilt
wurde, was wir ihm auch vorgeworfen haben in meinem Fall, aber in meinem Fall
war das komplett unglaubwürdig, laut dem Gericht. Warum sollte jemand sowas machen?
Aber wie auch immer, also dieser Lobby ist weiterhin tätig für die Novomatic
offenbar. Was kurios ist, weil ich habe tatsächlich in meinem Job für Großkonzerne
gearbeitet und ich weiß es aus meiner Erfahrung, Großkonzerne hassen nichts
mehr als Bad Publicity. Speziell in diesem Art Umfeld.
Und die Novomatic ist normal in Geschäftsfeldern tätig, die sehr sensibel reguliert
sind, unter anderem in Amerika, die Glücksspielkommission in Las Vegas ist bekannt
dafür, dass sie bei Korruptionsvorwürfen sehr ungehalten reagiert, sage ich mal.
Also normalerweise würde man davon ausgehen, dass ein Konzern wie die Normatik
aus reinem Eigeninteresse so jemanden abstößt und von sich weist.
Das wäre der normale logische Schritt. Das ist nicht passiert.
Warum auch immer dem so ist, die Normatik, wie gesagt, bestreitet das und es
gibt auch keinen Beweis, dass die Normatik damit zu tun hat.
Nichtsdestotrotz, Krügspiellobby hat also Zahlungen geleistet an diese Zeugen
in Höhe von knapp, ich glaube, was war es? 100.000 Euro knapp,
glaube ich, haben wir hochgerechnet.
Das sind die belegten Zahlungen. Offen gesagt gehen wir davon aus,
dass es deutlich mehr waren, aber wie auch immer.
Warum sind diese Zahlungen erfolgt und in welchem Umstand sind diese Zahlungen erfolgt?
Der Punkt war, um ganz am Anfang zurückzugehen,
zu veröffentlichen, das nochmal als des Ibiza-Videos, dieser Glücksspiel-Lobbyist
findet diese zwei ehemaligen freien Mitarbeiter von mir, trifft sich mit ihnen,
die sagen ihm, hey, hey, wir können dir Informationen geben,
machen einen Vertrag mit ihm, wo drinnen steht, okay, wir liefern dir Informationen,
dafür zahlst du uns mal 40.000.
Euro und du hast 10 Tage Zeit, die Informationen zu prüfen und wenn sie stimmen, zahlst du.
Der unterschreibt das und zahlt am nächsten Tag 40.000 Euro,
wie auch immer er die Information so schnell überprüft hat, weiß ich.
Die Information war noch falsch, nachweislich, aber egal.
Und dann, ein paar Tage später, gibt es noch eine E-Mail, wo die ihm schreiben,
hey, für 15.000 Euro sagen wir dir, wer die Oligarchin ist.
Und er sagt, ja, super, schickt 15.000 Euro. Und dann gehen wir also zu Gericht
und wir fragen also diese Zeugen, diese ehemaligen Mitarbeiter von mir.
Ihr habt 15.000 Euro bekommen laut E-Mail, damit ihr erzählt wer die Oligarch
ist. Wer ist sie denn nun? Ja, wissen wir nicht.
Ja, okay, aber ihr habt ja 15.000 Euro gekassiert, habt ihr ihn betrogen oder
was? Warum hat er dann gezahlt? Ja, weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Okay, dann haben wir also diesen Lobbyisten vorgeladen als Zeugen und haben
gesagt, okay, sie haben jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 60, 70.000 Euro an diese Leute gezahlt.
Warum denn? Wofür denn? Sie haben sich mit denen getroffen, irgendwie eine Stunde
lang auf einer Raststation und danach zahlen sie denen mal 40.000 Euro und ein
paar Tage später 15.000 Euro. Was haben die ihnen in der 1-2 Stunden geliefert?
Das ist ja ein ziemlich guter Stundensatz.
Nee, das ist nicht so zu sehen. Er hat die Informationslieferungen auf die nächsten
6 Monate hinaus gezahlt. Okay gut.
Was für verifizierte Informationen haben die denn geliefert?
Naja, das kann man jetzt nicht so sagen, es waren schon wertvolle Informationen
dabei. Ähm, Moment. Da sagen wir, okay, also für sechs Monate war diese erste Zahlung gedacht, ja.
Warum haben sie fünf Tage später weitere 15.000 Euro gezahlt?
Ja, das kann ich jetzt nicht so genau sagen. Okay, gut, gibt eine E-Mail,
wo drin steht, sie zahlen 15.000 Euro für die Identität der Oligarchin.
Können Sie uns sagen, wer die Oligarchin ist? Nein, leider nicht.
Könnte es sein, dass sie das Geld für was ganz anderes gezahlt haben?
Nein, natürlich nicht. Der weiß das weit von sich.
Das alles war für alle Anwesenden, ich glaube, ich spreche da auch für die Prozessbeobachter,
unter anderem Thomas da hinten, war reichlich absurd.
Der Richter hat das anders gesehen, so wie er so ziemlich alles anders gesehen
hat, als die anwesenden Personen in dem Gerichtssaal.
Es lief darauf hinaus, dass nach sieben Monaten der Richter zu dem Schluss kam,
dass ja, die Zeugen haben Geld erhalten und es ist unklar warum.
Ja, es gibt eine Menge Zweifel an dem Verfahren. Ja, die Zeugen widersprechen sich permanent.
Ja, die Zeugen bezichtigen sich gegenseitig als Lügner und dass sie Wahnvorstellungen
haben und Drogensüchtig sind und generell irgendwie schlechte Menschen.
Aber genau das macht sie glaubwürdig.
Moment.
Warum?
Weil wenn unser Vorwurf stimmen würde, dass das ein Komplott wäre,
dann hätten diese Zeugen sich ja abgestimmt und würden beide ohne Widersprüche
die gleiche Geschichte erledigen.
Und weil sie das nicht tun, ist das Beweis, dass sie sich nicht abgestimmt haben
und deswegen sagen sie die Wahrheit und daher schuldig, dreieinhalb Jahre Gefängnis.
Danke, Wiedersehen. Das war das.
Also ich bin offiziell verurteilter Drogendealer. Wir sind dann...
Ganz kurze Frage. Diese beiden Leute, denen eigentlich nachgewiesen wurde,
dass sie sechs Kilo gehandelt haben.
Jetzt haben die gesagt, irgendwie 1,25 von dir.
Hat sich irgendjemand dafür interessiert, wo die anderen herkommen?
Ne, das ist lustig. Ich habe ja viele Ermittlungsverfahren gesehen in meiner Zeit.
Es hat sich keine Sau für interessiert?
Ne, es gibt nicht einmal die Frage woher. Das witzige ist ja,
die haben ja damit argumentiert, diese zwei Zeugen, weil wir gesagt haben, okay, warum?
Ihr habt's am Anfang, der eine hat gesagt, das stimmt nicht,
ich hab ihm keinen Koks verkauft, der hat seine Aussage geändert,
warum denn? Ja, weil er seine Seele erleichtern wollte, er wollte sich reinwaschen.
Ja, klar.
Haben wir gesagt, ja, ist ja kein Problem, glauben wir dir alles,
du willst ein besserer Mensch werden, dann sag doch, wer hat denn den anderen fünf Kilo geliefert?
Ja, will er nicht sagen. Ja, aber warum denn nicht? Du willst ja deine Seele
reinigen, was ist denn das Problem? Ne, will er nicht sagen.
Hatte ich die Polizei so ein bisschen reinigt?
So ein bisschen. 55.000 Euro.
Ja oder so, wie viel auch immer. Es gibt die Unschuldsvermutung.
Ne, der Punkt ist, also, das hat tatsächlich, wir haben ihn dann gefragt,
hatte ich die Polizei denn jemals gefragt, woher diese anderen 5 Kilo kamen? Ne, warum denn?
Also das ist das erste Ermittlungsverfahren, das ich jemals gesehen habe.
Ich habe eine noch gewichtsgost nicht geringe Menge gesehen an Ermittlungsverfahren,
wo sich die Polizei nicht dafür interessiert, woher 5 Kilo Kokain importiert werden.
Ist vielleicht eine äußere Spezialität, ich weiß es nicht, aber es ist eine
der Auffälligkeiten des Verfahrens, sage ich mal. Einer der vielen.
Du hast einfach zu wenig geliefert.
Ja, das kann sein.
Oder die haben einfach...
Ich glaube, das Hauptproblem war tatsächlich, dass...
Freundin von ihm einfach am Anfang davon geredet hat, dass es 900 Gramm waren.
Dann hat er schon irgendwie hochgedreht mit, nee, die hat es nicht dargestellt.
Das Problem ist, es gab tatsächlich, die waren so dämlich und haben Buchhaltung geführt.
Und deswegen war es schwierig, dass irgendwie, also dass wir es ein bisschen
raufdrehen können, auf 6 Kilo sind sie einfach nicht gekommen.
Warum auch immer die gute Frau gesagt hat, sie hat sie 6 Kilo verkauft,
vielleicht stimmt das sogar wirklich und sie haben über die Jahre hinweg 6 Kilo
verkauft, ich weiß es nicht.
Aber irgendwie war es halt nicht möglich, mir die 6 Kilo zuzuordnen,
auch nur fiktional offenbar.
Aber es ist halt nichtsdestotrotz auffällig, dass es niemanden offenbar beim
Bundeskriminalamt in Österreich interessiert, woher fünf Kilo Kokain kommen, aber gut, soll so sein.
Die waren irgendwie Mitarbeiter von dir?
Die waren freie Mitarbeiter. Also Punkt war, wir waren früher,
früher gemeinsam in einer Firma tätig, wo ich auch quasi frei angestellt war.
Und nachher als ich meine Firma übernahm, übernahm ich die als freie Mitarbeiter,
weil die in ihrer Funktion als V-Leute extrem gute Zugänge zu den Polizeibehörden hatten.
Und in Österreich ist es, wie man vielleicht im Wirecard Fall gemerkt hat,
ist guter Zugang zu den Behörden in Österreich, lässt sich ummützen,
in guter Informationsfluss aus Behörden raus.
Oh man ey.
Und das kann durchaus hilfreich sein, sag ich mal.
Dreieinhalb Jahre Urteil stehen jetzt am Ende des Verfassens.
Ja, dreieinhalb Jahre Urteil, da sitze ich jetzt schon so knapp zwei Jahre fast.
Also eigentlich nicht mehr, blödsinn, 18 Monate, also 19 Monate.
Wir gehen also in Berufung.
In Österreich gibt es tatsächlich im Gegensatz zu Deutschland keine Tatsachenstanz,
kein zweites. Das heißt der Punkt ist in Österreich so, das ist auch eine österreichische
Spezialität, wenn du in Österreich verurteilt wirst und der Richter,
es gilt in jedem Rechtssystem oder in jedem westlichen Rechtssystem gilt die
freie Beweiswürdigung.
Das heißt es obliegt dem Richter die Beweise frei zu würdigen.
Das heißt, der Richter beurteilt unabhängig von der Beweislage,
prinzipiell unabhängig von der Beweislage in seiner Einschätzung das Gewicht der Beweise.
Und in Österreich ist es nun mal so, dass wenn ein Richter in einem Verfahren,
das einem Strafrahmen von fünf Jahren übersteigt, zu dem Schluss kommt,
dass die Beweise so zu sehen sind, wie er sie sieht, kannst du das in der oberen
Instanz nicht mehr bekämpfen.
Das heißt, wenn ein Richter einmal sagt, der Zeug ist glaubwürdig,
obwohl er lügt, ist das so. Das ist zementiert.
Das geht auch in der nächsten Instanz nicht mehr. Du kannst in der nächsten
Instanz nur mehr die Formalität bekämpfen.
Du kannst nicht mehr sagen, der hat formale Fehler gemacht, der hat keine Ahnung was.
Also du kannst nicht mehr sagen, der Richter hat die Beweise falsch gewürdigt. Das heißt,
wenn du einen verrückten oder einen sonst irgendwie anders motivierten Richter hast,
aus was auch immer für einem Grund, der beschließt, er will ein komplett absurdes
Urteil fällen, dann ist deine Chance, das Urteil aufzuheben,
nicht gerade gut in Österreich, weil du die Beweiswürdigung nicht bekämpfen
kannst. Das war in meinem Fall auch so.
Obergericht ist dann zurückgekommen und hat gesagt, nee, das war die Beweiswürdigung
des Richters und es gibt zwei Zeugen und die mögen ja gelogen haben,
aber wir haben am Ende nicht beweisen können, dass diese Zeugen Geld erhalten
haben, um Falschaussagen zu tätigen, was wiederum eine recht juristisch spezielle Position ist.
Es gab ja immerhin Zahlungen.
Ja, aber wenn du einem Angeklagten sagst, du hast nicht beweisen können,
das ist so, das Staat muss dir beweisen normalerweise.
In Österreich ist das Rechtssystem ein bisschen pervertiert,
weil es in Strafverfahren oft so ist, dass du dich quasi frei beweisen musst.
Also es kommt ein Vorwurf und dann wird es von dir erwartet und dann beweist
man, dass es nicht so ist.
Das Problem ist, ich hab das auch vor Gericht vorgebracht, weil tatsächlich
die Leute gesagt haben, naja hey, wenn du es nicht warst, dann wirst du beweisen
können, dass das nicht stimmt.
Ich hab gesagt, na Moment mal, der Punkt ist, der Vorwurf ist, irgendwann 2017, 2018,
hab ich irgendwann entlang der Route Wien-München und ich hab in München meine
Firma, also jeder Mensch weiß, dass ich von Wien nach München pendle regelmäßig,
auf der Route Wien-München ein Kilo Kokain übergeben.
Das ist so, wie wenn ich irgendjemandem hier sagen würde, irgendwann letztes
Jahr bist du auf deinem Weg zur Arbeit stehen geblieben und hast jemanden getroffen.
Das ist vielleicht falsch, aber beweist mal, dass es nicht so ist.
Das ist ziemlich unmöglich. Und das war die Problematik an dem Vorwurf.
Er war so inkonkret, du kannst nicht frei beweisen.
Du kannst Widersprüche aufzeigen, kannst alles mögliche. Aber wenn du halt einen
Richter hast, der sagt, je mehr Widersprüche, desto glaubwürdiger werden die
Zeugen. Was willst du machen?
Keine Widersprüche mehr aufdecken.
Nee, das war ja das, was sie von mir wollten. Es gab ja immer wieder so mehr
oder weniger verklausulisierte Angebote.
Ich soll doch das Urteil akzeptieren, ich soll nicht berufen,
dann kriegt ihr elektronische Fußfessel und kann gehen.
Es ging nicht darum, mich jetzt irgendwie, denen war es komplett egal,
ob ich jetzt ein Jahr eingesperrt bin, fünf Jahre oder zehn Jahre, darum ging es nicht.
Die wollten unwidersprochen in Zeitungen stehen haben können,
hey, der Typ, der Überzeuger macht das, ist ein Krimineller.
Und weil sie wussten, dass der Fall, den sie da verurteilt hatten, einfach so dünn ist,
dass jeder, der ihn anschaut, gesehen hat, dass es schwachsinnig ist,
war halt immer jetzt das Manko über der Verurteilung, dass die Hälfte der Bevölkerung
sagt, naja gut, das ist ein bisschen seltsam und schaut irgendwie nicht so politisch
motiviert aus und die andere Hälfte sagt, ey, scheiß Drogendealer,
hat bekommen, was er verdient.
Aber der Punkt ist halt, sie wollten es clean haben. Sie wollten einfach,
kommt nicht nochmal auf die dämliche Idee her, sowas wie Jubelzahl zu machen,
weil es jetzt eh was passiert.
Darum ging's. Und das ist halt was wir ihnen nicht gegeben haben,
was ich ihnen nicht gegeben habe.
Wofür ich aber am Ende auch relativ teuer bezahlt habe, weil der Unterschied
war nochmal irgendwie 14 Monate obendrauf, die ich halt extra gemacht habe.
Weil du musst dann natürlich in Haft bleiben, solange die Berufung rennt,
weil du nicht rechtskräftig verurteilt bist. Solange du nicht rechtskräftig
verurteilt bist, hast du kein Anrecht auf bedingte Entlassung etc.
So gesehen, das war also die Problematik dahinter. Das heißt,
dieser Widerstand hat mich nochmal 14 Monate Gefängnis extra gekostet.
Zusätzlich zu 18 vorher.
Nee, das erste Angebot kam vor dem Urteilsschluss.
Also insgesamt hätte ich quasi 14 Monate weniger machen müssen.
Mit 14 Monaten hätte ich gehen können, weil die mir die Halbstrafe,
wie es in Österreich heißt, also 50 Prozent nachgelassen hätten,
Plus die Fußfessel auf zwölf Monate, dann bist du bei keine Ahnung was.
Also wie lange warst du jetzt insgesamt im Gefängnis?
28 Monate im Gefängnis, ey fuck it.
Und jetzt ist es aber … Jetzt krieg ich Bewährung?
Ja, ich bin nicht im Gefängnis offen.
Ja, die Vermutung hatte ich schon.
Hey, kein Plot Twist. Wir haben mit den Lockpickern gesprochen.
Wir wollten nur kurz, dass du deine Aussage machst, dann kommst du wieder knapp.
Ne, also ich hab jetzt 14 Monate Bewährung offen, das heißt in den nächsten
drei Jahren, wenn ich theoretisch rein formal theoretisch bei Rot über die Ampel
gehe, in Österreich zumindest, kann ich 14 weitere Monate ins Gefängnis eingesperrt werden.
Was wohl so ein gewisses Damoklesschwert ist, deswegen bin ich auch so in gewissen
Aussagen recht gehemmt und vorsichtig,
die ich da tätige, weil auch sowas wie eine Verleumdung, Ehrenbeleidigung,
ähnliches dazu dienlich ist, deswegen bin ich etwas vorsichtig in meiner Einschätzung
von anderen involvierten Stellen und Personen, aber ja.
Und die Novomatik schaut sich natürlich alles an. Schönen Gruß an die Kollegen.
Sag mal, was hast du denn jetzt sozusagen, was nimmst du denn daraus mit?
Also ich meine, du warst ja vorher wahrscheinlich jetzt auch schon so ein bisschen
im Bilde darüber, wie so Österreich so drauf ist. Du hast ja schon gesagt,
dass dich dann doch letztlich in diesem ganzen Prozess einiges überrascht hat.
Ja ne, schau, der Punkt ist, mir war schon klar, wie Österreich drauf ist,
aber ich hatte eben darauf gesetzt, und das war auch mit ein Grund,
warum ich die EU-Wahl für ein sinnvolles Datum erkoren hatte,
weil ich davon ausging, dass internationaler Druck oder Aufmerksamkeit die Österreicher
darin hemmen würde, ihre komplette Perversität auszupacken, sag ich mal.
Das war nicht so. Ich habe auch gelernt, dass wenn es um Rechtsschutz geht,
solange das irgendwie innereuropäisch ist.
Brauchst du jetzt auch nicht allzu viel erwarten von der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
oder so, also die sind dann auch nicht irgendwie, solange es nicht die Bundesrepublik
betrifft, sind die dann schon irgendwie groß vorab mit der Fahne schwenkend,
von wegen Menschenrechte und sonst was.
Aber sobald sie selber involviert sind, sind sie dann auch recht schnell dich
irgendwie rauszuschmeißen, weil sie einfach den Stress nicht haben wollen.
Also das habe ich schon auch gelernt.
Auch meine Anwälte, ich weiß, ich hatte einen Anwalt, der lustigerweise auch
den Assange vertreten hat eine Zeit lang.
Und der hat halt gemeint, ich hab immer gedacht, wenn der Assange in Deutschland
verhaftet worden wäre, dann hätten wir ihn geschützt, dann hätten wir ihn...
Und er sagt mittlerweile, glaube ich das nicht mehr.
Mittlerweile glaube ich, dass es genauso gelaufen wäre wie bei dir,
weil sich der Staat einfach nicht das nicht antun will.
Wie dem auch sei, ich glaube, was man aus dem Sache jetzt genereller und breiter
mitnehmen kann, ist, die Mechaniken, die wirken, sind meistens gleich, glaube ich.
Das ist etwas, was man generell sagen kann, wenn man sich jetzt diverse,
und ich will mich da überhaupt nicht vergleichen, also ich finde das immer,
es gab ab und an jetzt immer wieder so Vergleiche, ich finde das Ibiza ist Ibiza
und alles schön und gut, aber das ist nochmal was komplett anderes,
das Non-Understand und sonst was, der Vergleich ist ehrenvoll,
aber ich würde ihn so nicht treffen wollen.
Aber wie dem auch sei, die Mechaniken sind trotzdem gleich, also der Punkt ist immer das gleiche,
es wird versucht quasi, die Leute zu delegitimieren,
Also jemand kommt, bringt irgendwas an die Öffentlichkeit, dann versucht man
ihn zu delegitimieren, dann versucht man ihn unter Druck zu bringen,
dann versucht man ihn mit irgendwelchen Vorwürfen mal öffentlich so in eine
Ecke zu rücken, dass der öffentliche Rückhalt wegfällt und dann versucht man ihn zu erledigen.
Und das wird praktiziert und das wird erfolgreich praktiziert.
Ich glaube das ist auch etwas, womit man sich, wenn man realistisch ist,
auch wenn das vielleicht nicht wünschenswert ist, womit man sich auseinandersetzen sollte,
nämlich dass eigentlich kaum ein Fall,
zumindest mir bekannt ist, von einem Whistleblower, wenn man so will,
und ich will mich jetzt auch da nicht unbedingt einreihen, aber ich sag's nur,
der öffentlich bekannt wurde, der, wo's gut ausgegangen ist, sag ich mal.
Und das hat ja auch Methode, ne?
Ja, ich sag ja, das ist die Methode. Also es geht, es ist auch weniger der Rache,
glaube ich, weil immer die Leute sagen, nee, es geht um ein Exempel statuieren.
Es geht einfach darum, dass du so bis zu einem gewissen Grad gehen kannst,
aber so, wenn du einen gewissen gerade überschreitest, dann ist einfach der Impuls,
ein Exempel zu statuieren und da ist es eigentlich schon fast teilweise gewollt,
dass das Exempel möglichst absurd ausfällt, damit die breite Masse wahrnimmt,
dass eben das, weil sonst könnte man sagen, okay das ist einfach ein normales
Strafverfahren, aber das ist schon gewünscht auch.
Also diese Absurdität ist bis zu einem gewissen Grad, bin ich mittlerweile überzeugt,
auch gewünscht, damit die Leute halt den Abschreckungseffekt sehen.
Weil jetzt ist es eben egal, wie unschuldig du bist, egal wie sauber du bist
egal wie moralisch edel, sonst was du bist, du bist erledigt,
wenn du so einen Blödsinn machst.
Und das ist glaube ich, worum es eigentlich geht und ich glaube,
das ist, worüber man auch in breiterer Form diskutieren konnte,
was man auch diskutieren sollte und was man, weiß nicht, wie man es ändern kann,
aber es ist definitiv etwas, weil...
Überleg mal, wie viele durchaus wirklich relevante, ich will jetzt nicht sagen
Weltbewegungen, aber relevante Sachen in den letzten Jahren über Whistleblower herausgekommen sind.
Also überleg, wie viele Leute da irgendwo rumsitzen, die noch viele relevantere
Sachen wissen und auch durchaus sagen wollen würden, die nicht trauen.
Weil sie eben gesehen haben, was Leuten passiert, wie mit denen umgegangen wird,
was für Kosten sie tragen müssen, was für Konsequenzen sie zu tragen haben.
Und das ist glaube ich, also wenn man da was ändern kann, also wenn man wirklich jetzt sagt,
für sich, ich meine es gibt ja auch Leute, die sagen, es ist alles super wie
es ist und warum will man einem funktionierenden System rumfuschen,
aber für den Teil, der sagt, okay, es ist nicht so geil und da gibt es irgendwie
genug Sachen, die nicht gut sind, dann sollte man da vielleicht ansetzen.
Weil da gibt es mit Sicherheit, also immer wieder, am Ende des Tages,
glaube ich, ist noch kein System von außen geändert worden, sondern immer nur
von innen, wenn du so willst.
Und das ist vielleicht auch eine Analogie zu dem, was hier ist, wegen CCC.
Im Endeffekt ist es, das ist jetzt überspitzt gesagt, aber Hacking ist ja auch
nichts anderes. Du gehst rein und von drinnen machst du es quasi.
Und das ist das gleiche. Also du wirst nicht von außen, wenn du von außen einfach
nur dagegen rennst, dann wirst du vielleicht irgendwann einbrechen,
aber der Effekt ist nicht das gleiche.
Es ist immer effektiver, wenn du von drinnen rauskommst. Es ist am Ende auch
das, was ich in meinem vorherigen Job gemacht habe. Wir haben es halt anders
genannt. Ihr nennt es Social Engineering und wir haben es halt,
keine Ahnung, Infiltration oder was auch immer genannt.
Aber der Punkt ist noch immer das Gleiche. Es passiert immer auf dem Gleichen.
Du versuchst dich also nicht mit dem Kopf durch die Wand gegen das System anzurennen,
sondern versuchst dich halt irgendwie mal zu integrieren und irgendwie anzupassen
und dann von drinnen heraus zu wirken.
Und das ist auch, glaube ich, der effektivste und effizienteste Weg und auch
der weitestführendste Weg. Aber der Punkt ist, du musst es halt den Leuten noch
ermöglichen, bzw. ihnen Rahmenbedingungen schaffen, wo sie es machen wollen.
Es gibt sicher genug Leute, die der Überzeugung sind, hey, es reicht irgendwann.
Ich meine, Menschen sind am Ende Menschen und jeder hat irgendwann mal so das
Gefühl in sich gehabt, hey, das geht nicht mehr, das ist zu viel,
das ist eine Sauerei, eine Schweinerei.
Und dann sieht er halt so Leute wie keiner Assange oder was,
der dann sieben Jahre lang irgendwo in einer Botschaft hockt oder was auch immer
und jetzt vielleicht irgendwie nochmal 100 Jahre unterobkriegt.
Und da überlegst du dir dreimal, klar.
Und das sind so Sachen, glaube ich, die... Darüber sollte man reden und diskutieren,
das sind die wichtigsten Sachen.
Du wirst dem Impuls der Gegenseite, wenn du so willst, nicht vorbauen können,
dass dieses Exempel statuiert werden soll und will.
Aber wenn du es ermöglichst, dass solche Absurditäten nicht so leicht stattfinden,
weil sie stattfinden nur, wenn die Öffentlichkeit wegschaut oder sich blenden
lässt mit irgendwelchen Fake-Vorwürfen, Delegitimierungen und sonst irgendwas.
Beim Ende des Tages, das ist das, was uns vielleicht, und ich sage absichtlich
uns, weil ich es nicht immer auf mich beziehen will, uns, Gemeinde und Anwalt
auch, bei Ibiza gefehlt hat, war eben dieser öffentliche Rückhalt.
War ja auch unser Fehler, weil wir eben damals die Macht der Öffentlichkeit
unterschätzt haben. Also wir sind eben nicht öffentlich gegangen und haben nicht
öffentlich erklärt, was wie wo.
Auch mit anderem, weil wir eben noch diese Bodyguard-Infos zu verwerten hatten
und dass beides nicht gleichzeitig möglich war.
Aber der Punkt ist trotzdem der, dass nicht jeder dieser Leute,
die Informationen an die Öffentlichkeit tragt, wird perfekt sein.
Die meisten sind es wahrscheinlich nicht.
Viele davon mögen durchaus ihre Fehler haben und ich will jetzt gar keinen Namen
nennen, aber ich habe schon gehört, dass charakterlich manche davon nicht unbedingt
die angenehmsten Leute sein sollen.
Aber das macht keinen Unterschied. Es geht nicht darum, dass du jetzt jemanden
findest, der irgendwie ein super shiny white irgendwas ist, sondern der Punkt
ist… Die Zahl der perfekten Menschen ist auch sehr überschaubar.
Ja, da haben wir zu wenige von.
Davon.
Wie machst du jetzt weiter?
Tja, das ist eine gute Frage. Also eigentlich, ich bin ja erst im April rausgekommen
und habe jetzt irgendwie so mit acht Wochen oder was eigentlich selbst verschrieben gehabt.
Medienrummel, einfach weil ich meine Sicht der Dinge darlegen wollte und habe
mir dann eigentlich vorgenommen, irgendwie so einen längeren Campingurlaub zu
machen, den ich nicht gemacht habe, aber das kann ich hier nachholen mit dem
Zelt, so gesehen ist es schon.
Aber nee, ich bastle an einem neuen Leben, wenn du so willst und das ist kompliziert
genug mit all dem Drum und Dran.
Ich suche irgendwie, weil einerseits, zu meinem eigenen Erstaunen,
ist dieser Medienrummel,
wenn du so willst, hat recht viel Anklang auch in Österreich gefunden,
was mir sowas wie ein politisches Gewicht verliehen hat, bis zu einem gewissen
Grad, dass ich durchaus geneigt bin zu nutzen, soweit es mir möglich ist und
soweit ich die Gelegenheit dazu bekomme.
Versuche ich halt auch noch immer irgendwie mir sowas zumindest zu bauen,
was halt normal sowas wie Leben bedeutet, also Einkommen etc., was auch immer, Job.
Und ich versuche momentan, ich fahre natürlich das Kreis, ich versuche halt
irgendwie einen Job zu finden, der mir erlaubt, irgendwie locationunabhängig
zu arbeiten, im besten Fall. Und gleichzeitig die Zeit und Möglichkeiten erlaubt,
mich noch immer da politisch und sonst wie zu betätigen.
Gleichzeitig bin ich in den Anfangsstadien einer Gründung einer Plattform,
wenn man so will, nennen wir es mal, mit ein paar anderen, glaube ich zumindest
in Österreich bekannten Gesichtern, um da weitere Thematiken zu bearbeiten,
die da offen liegen, sage ich mal, mit Hinblick auf österreichische Politik etc.
Da hoffe ich, dass wir irgendwann im Herbst soweit sind, dass wir da irgendwie
starten können und hergehen können, wenn man so will.
Und ja, ansonsten, mein Gott, ich suche, wie gesagt, Jobs suche ich noch immer,
wenn da irgendjemand irgendwas weiß, was so locationunabhängig und Teilzeitmäßig
funktioniert, immer gern zu mir.
Aber ansonsten bin ich, glaube ich jetzt dann danach, werde ich hoffentlich
mal wirklich in den Urlaub einlegen. Das ist so momentan das, was der Verfassung ist.
Würde ich empfehlen. Das war ja nun wirklich ein wilder Ritt und das geht ja
natürlich auch extrem auf die Psyche.
Vielleicht so zum Abschluss, was ist denn so, was würdest du sagen hast du gelernt über unsere Systeme?
Ich rede jetzt bewusst mal nicht von Österreich, weil Österreich ist ja eigentlich
auch nur ein Extrem unter vielen und letztlich reden wir ja hier über Machtstrukturen,
die zwangsläufig da sind, die sich so nie wahrscheinlich komplett verhindern
lassen und man hat halt mehr oder weniger krasse funktionierende Kontrollen,
ja, also krasse Auswüchse und funktionierende Kontrollen.
In manchen Staaten ist es irgendwie etwas balancierter, weil sie mehr Geld haben,
mehr Tradition haben, was weiß ich,
weil es aus irgendwelchen Gründen funktioniert und in anderen weniger,
aber so mal jetzt so ganz allgemein gesprochen, was hat dich das gelehrt über
unser Zusammenleben und über unsere Systeme, wie gut sie funktionieren oder
wie gut sie funktionieren könnten?
Nur was ich gelernt habe, ist einerseits für mich, und das war etwas,
was ich vielleicht in meiner Naivität so nicht wahrgenommen hatte, ist, dass...
Medien bilden Meinung und die Meinung ist oft gebildet durch nicht unbedingt
perfekte Informationen, sage ich mal.
Also ich war erstaunt darüber, was für Schwachsinn auch von Qualitätsmedien
veröffentlicht wurde, einfach nur um irgendwas zu veröffentlichen und das bildet
dann aber auch die Meinung der Leute, setzt den Narrativ.
Weil irgendwann muss man so eine Information bekommen. Ich habe gelernt,
dass Fake News erstaunlich effektiv ist, wenn sie einfach oft genug wiederholt wird.
Also das ist etwas, was ich auch gelernt habe. Das ist komplett wurscht,
wie schwachsinnig es ist, wenn du es einfach hundertmal in die Öffentlichkeit
posaunst und es wird nicht widersprochen, dann ist es irgendwie ein normaler Fakt einfach.
Das ist auch etwas, was ich so nicht wahrgenommen hatte.
Ich habe gelernt, dass, mehr prinzipiell gesprochen,
dort wo Intransparenz herrscht,
also wo die Öffentlichkeit nicht hinschauen kann, passieren Dinge,
die nicht passieren sollten, weil sie halt weil es der einfachste Weg ist,
sage ich mal. Das trifft auch auf Behörden zu.
Ich glaube, es wird generell, da bin ich relativ legitimiert dazu zu sprechen,
es wird glaube ich generell, vielleicht hier in dem Umfeld ein bisschen weniger,
aber nichtsdestotrotz dennoch glaube ich unterschätzt, wie weit Behörden Grenzen denen beugen,
brechen können in ihrer Suche nach einem Ziel, das sie erreichen wollen.
Ich glaube, es wird auch unterschätzt, wie...
Die meisten oder viele Leute sehen Behörden so als ein monolithisches Konstrukt
und Behörden sind am Ende eine Ansammlung von einzelnen Charakteren und diese
Charaktere sind oft nicht die besten.
Und ich glaube das wird auch unterschätzt, wie sehr da auch persönliche Anonymitäten
mitspielen teilweise, also wie oft es auch einfach genügt, wenn du da irgendjemanden
hast, der gegen dich ermittelt, arbeitet sonst was, der dir einfach aus irgendeinem
Grund nicht leiden kann.
Das macht einen Riesenunterschied zu jemandem, der dich ganz cool findet am Ende des Tages.
Ich glaube, es wird unterschätzt, wie unkritisch Staatsanwaltschaften behördliche
Ermittlungsergebnisse übernehmen.
Also quasi ihrem Auftrag, die Ermittlungen zu prüfen, nicht nachkommen in Wirklichkeit.
Ich glaube, auch das lässt sich generell behaupten.
Es gibt viele Gründe dafür, sicher die Unterfinanzierung, Überlastung und sonst
was, aber nichts daraus ist es so.
Weil einfach Polizei ist Polizei. Ich sag immer, Polizei sind wie Hunde.
Die haben einen Spieltrieb und den wollen sie erfüllt haben.
Und wenn sie ihren Spieltrieb nicht erfüllt kriegen, dann sind sie einfach bissig.
Und ja, es ist so. Also das ist zutreffend.
Und das meine ich jetzt gar nicht despektierlich, aber es ist einfach so.
Also das sind halt Leute, ich kenn das aus meinem eigenen Ding,
wenn du an was arbeitest, willst du ein Erfolgserlebnis haben.
Das Problem ist halt, wenn du dich verrannt hast und dann etwas arbeitest,
was nicht funktioniert, dann bist du halt frustriert. Und wenn du bei einer
Position bist, wo du deine Frustration in deinem Erfolg ändern kannst,
indem du halt da einen Knopf drehst und da einen Knopf drehst,
dann wirst du früher oder später relativ rasch Charaktere finden,
die bereit sind, das zu tun.
Und das ist der Anfang von solchen Sachen. Weil ich glaube, man sieht das immer
so als die große Verschwörung.
Nee, ist es nie. Da haben sich vorher 20 Leute zusammengesetzt und haben irgendwie
gebrainstormt und einen Masterplan gemacht, wie sie sich erledigen.
Da sind einzelne Akteure, die Schritte setzen und der andere sieht,
wie das funktioniert und da setzen wir noch was drauf und da setzen wir noch
was drauf und am Ende kommt sowas dabei raus. Und ich glaube,
das ist, was man realisieren muss.
Und da sollte man irgendwelche Strukturen bauen, um dem vorzubereiten.
Applaus Ja Julian, ich sag mal vielen vielen Dank für die Einblicke in deine
wilde Reise, so hoch motiviert und schwer bestraft.
Beides zutreffen. Also du hast auf jeden Fall ordentlich eingesteckt für uns
alle eigentlich und das kann man dir hoch anrechnen.
Ich hoffe es läuft jetzt besser für dich.
Ich auch. Dankeschön.
Hüpfen. Es war uns eine Freude und Ehre und ich glaube, viel mehr haben wir gar nicht zu sagen.
Teilweise kommen am Ende der Sendung manchmal Menschen zu Tim oder mir,
die irgendwie zu viel Bargeld haben und uns bitten, da beim Tragen zu helfen.
Ich glaube, es ist klar, dass es nach dieser Sendung nicht an uns geht,
sondern an Julian und ich glaube, damit können wir uns den wohlverdienten Abend verabschieden.
Können wir gemeinsam trinken, falls du nicht so Zeit hast.
Genau. Vielen Dank Julian, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Das war Logbuch Netzpolitik 466 live vom Chaos Communication Camp.
Habt noch ein schönes Camp.